MAKING SEVERAL ANNOUNCEMENTS
TODAY TO EXPLAIN THE PROCESS
WE'VE DEVELOPED TO CONTINUE OUR
CENTRAL WORK DURING THE
PANDEMIC. FOR THOSE OF YOU
FAMILIAR WITH THIS PROCESS WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE WHILE
I GO THROUGH IT AGAIN FOR THOSE
TUNING IN FOR THE FIRST TIME.
SELECT THE JUST QUICKLY COVER
THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS
FOR THE DAY. IN RESPONSE THE
CODE NINETEEN THE EMERGENCY IN
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
SENATORS SENATE STAFF. WE MUST
LIMIT NONESSENTIAL GATHERING
SENATE HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING. COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE AND LOCAL ORDERS THE
SENATE WILL BE HOLDING THIS
ESSENTIAL HEARING AND IS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO
OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS BY
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC IN OUR
EMPLOYEES. SO TODAY'S HEARING
IS BEING HELD IN THE CAPITAL.
TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TWO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. BE USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANTS TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AND IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN. I THINK IT'S GOING TO
COME UP RIGHT NOW TODAY
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. OUR ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN FIVE ZERO TWO ZERO
ONE THREE ONE MORE TIME THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN FIVE ZERO TWO
ZERO ONE THREE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR
WILL IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY
OPEN YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME
YOU MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE.
PLEASE NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR
US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO
AVOID ANY FEEDBACK. YOU MUST
NHIáU THE DEVICE YOU ARE
WATCHING THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GETTING YOUR TESTIMONY OVER
THE PHONE. IT'S IMPORTANT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND SO WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY. AND IN
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED FROM
REMOTE HEARING. AT REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. SO WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS IN AS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIMES FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOLS. SO AGAIN PLEASE BE
PATIENT SO EVERYONE CAN BE
HEARD. AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
OUR STENOGRAPHER. LET ME ASK
ALL SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES AND
WITNESSES ALIKE TO SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY. WITH THAT. BEFORE
WE GET INTO TODAY'S AGENDA I
NEED TO HAVE A SUSTAINABLE SH A
QUORUM SO AS A REMINDER TO OUR
MEMBERS YOU'LL NEED TO TURN ON
YOUR MICROPHONE FOR THE ROLL
CALL AND EVERY TIME WE VOTE SO
MADAM SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. EIGHT HERE EIGHT
YEAR MINING HERE ON IN HERE
EIGHT RALPH HERE ROTH HERE WILK
PRESIDENT RESIDENT AT HERE
SINCE HERE. THANK YOU SO ON IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE THE AGENDA
LET ME SEE IF WE CAN AT FIRST
DISPENSED WITH ITEM NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS THE BILL
REFERRALS I WOULD ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. SO MOVED THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN FIVE MEN
OF SECRETARY WILL YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I MEAN I. ONE
NINE ONE THANK YOU FOR ALL. ROB
I WILL HI. I ATKINS I. HI THANK
YOU IS YOU NAM. IN A IN ORDER
TO FOR. OUR MEETING IN TURN OF
THE- X. NUMBER OF. A POINT
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR I'M GOING TO
ENTERTAIN THREE MOTIONS TO
FACILITATE THE FLOW BASED ON.
COMMENTS FROM OF MY COLLEAGUES
SO AS THE FIRST MOTION I WOULD
ENTERTAIN ITEM TO GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR ITEM TO SEE THROUGH SEE
SEE. I'LL GIVE YOU A MINUTE TO
LOOK AT THAT N. ENTERTAIN A
MOTION. MOVE THANK YOU SO MUCH
SENATOR ROTH. MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYBODY SEES WHAT WE'RE DOING
I WILL ASK MADAM SECRETARY TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BATES.
FIVE IT'S AYE MONNING AYE AYE
ROTH AYE ROTH AYE WILK HI I
ATKINS FIVE HI THE PASSES YOU
NEAR THE NEXT MOTION I WOULD
ASK FOR WOULD BE FOR ITEMS TO
DE DE THROUGH H. H. PLUS J. J.
LET ME GIVE YOU A SECOND TO
LOOK AT THAT. MADAM SECRETARY
WE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BUT
I'LL I'LL MAKE THE MOTION-
THANK YOU SO MUCH OF MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN SORRY A MOTION
WOULD BE IN ORDER. DONE I'M SO
GLAD TO BE BACKED UP BY. WE
WAITED VICE CHAIR YOU MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY CALL THE
ROLL. EIGHTH NOT VOTING
ABSTAINED. IT'S NOT VOTING
MONNING HI I MEAN I. ROTH RIGHT
ROTH AYE WILK HI AYE ATKINS
FIVE I THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT
PASSES FOR ZERO WITH ONE
ABSTENTION AND SO THE LAST OUR
MOTION I WOULD ASK FOR IS ITEMS
TO BUY HI. A MOTION TO MOVE
THANK YOU SENATOR MANI. MADAM
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL. EIGHTH
ABSTAINED IT'S NOT VOTING
VOTING MINING I MONNING I'D
ROTH ARE AYE WILK. WILL NOT
VOTING ATKINS. FIVE FIVE THAT
PASSED THROUGH TWO OUR- ZERO
TWO TWO ABSENT. THANK I GOT
THAT RIGHT YES OKAY. SO I NOW
THAT WE'VE THE OF GOVERNORS
APPOINTEES NOT REQUIRED TO
APPEAR. LET SIDE TURN OUR
ATTENTION TO THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
AND WE WILL START WITH DOCTOR
SONYA ANGEL THE DIRECTOR AND
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WELCOME DOCTOR ANGEL. IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU AGAIN- HI. WE'VE
BEEN A LOT OF TIME SEEING EACH
OTHER REMOTELY IT WOULD SAVE.
AND LET ME JUST ASK IF THERE'S
ANYONE WITH YOU THAT YOU WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE OUR KNOWLEDGE
WILL WELCOME THEM THAT MAKE
YOUR INTRODUCTORY REMARKS. AND
THEN WE'LL GO RIGHT INTO
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS FROM THE
SENATOR SO WELCOME. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY-
MY FAMILY MEMBERS ARE NOT ABLE
TO JOIN TODAY BUT I DO- THANK
THEM FOR THEIR SUPPORT-
ESPECIALLY DURING THIS TIME. SO
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DOCTOR SONYA ANGEL I
AM. DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND STATE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER. I AM
HONORED TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU
TODAY AND THANK GOVERNOR NEW SO
FOR THIS INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY
TO LEAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. PARTICULARLY AT
THIS TIME IN HISTORY. AS FOR MY
BACKGROUND AND EXPERIENCES. I
THINK THEY HELP ME BURKE YOU
NEED VALUABLE CRISP. AND SKILL
SET TO THIS DOES. AND TO
CALIFORNIA. I WAS MOST RECENTLY
DEPUTY COMMISSIONER AT THE NEW
YORK CITY DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH.
I SPENT TEN YEARS IN THAT
DEPARTMENT AND SO HAVE A STRONG
APPRECIATION FOR THE ROLE OF
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
ADVANCING POPULATION HEALTH. I
WAS ALSO SENIOR ADVISER AT THE
GLOBE FOR GLOBAL HEALTH AT THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
PREVENT AND PREVENTION IN
ATLANTA. ESPECIALLY DURING THIS
PANDEMIC THAT EXPERIENCE OF
THOSE RELATIONSHIPS HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY USEFUL IN WORKING
WITH OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS. I'M
PASSIONATE ABOUT COMMUNITY
HEALTH AND IMPORTANTLY I AM IT
I FEEL VERY STRONGLY ABOUT
USING DATA TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DRIVE OUR BEST BEST HELP OUT
COMES. AS A LATINA AND THE
FIRST TO LEAD THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH I
AM PROUD TO HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND COMMITTED TO
SUPPORTING OUR SHARED GOALS A
POPULATION HEALTH. AND HEALTH
EQUITY. I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND OTHERS NOT
ONLY TO ADDRESS OUR ON GOING
COULD WORK. BUT ALSO TO ADDRESS
THE MANY OTHER DISEASES IN
ISSUES THAT IMPACT THE HEALTH.
OF CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DOCTOR ANGEL THANK YOU SO
MUCH I THINK I WILL TURN FIRST
US SENATOR MONNING POINT YOU
STARTED SOFT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND- THANK YOU DOCTOR
ANGEL I WANT TO START BY
CONGRATULATING YOU ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT AND- THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME YOU FORGET ME
YESTERDAY WE HAD A GOOD
CONVERSATION. AND I KNOW HOW
BUSY BEEN ARM SINCE TAKING THE
HELM LARA WITH DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH IN WE APPRECIATE
THE- LONG HOURS THE YUNIOR
STAFF HAVE SERVED- I WANT TO GO
OVER SOME STARTING WITH THE WE
TALKED EXTENSIVELY ABOUT THE
COVERT NINETEEN RESPONSE. AND I
WANT TO FOCUS IN. SECURELY WE
DISCUSSED SOME PROVISION OF-
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT TO BOTH
HOSPITALS AND OTHER HEALTH
WORKERS CAN YOU PROVIDE US A
STATUS REPORT. ON THE STATE'S
ROLE PARTICULARLY WITH PRIVATE
SECTOR HOSPITALS AND- OTHER
COMMUNITY CLINICS HOSPITALS
WHAT IS THE- ROLE IN WHAT'S
YOUR CURRENT ASSESSMENT OF THE
AVAILABILITY OF PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. YEAH SO- IT ONE OF
THE KEY FOCUSES OF OUR WORK HAS
BEEN TO ENSURE THAT OUR CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM IS STRONG AND
THAT IT'S PREPARED TO RECEIVE
IF NECESSARY PATIENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CAN PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES AND
SAVE LIVES- PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT HAS BEEN AS WE ALL
KNOW- ONE OF THE MAJOR AREAS
WHERE WE HAVE FOCUSED A LOT OF
OUR WORK THAT IS BECAUSE THERE
HAS BEEN. A GLOBAL SHORTAGE
NATIONAL AND READ SHORTAGES
WERE SO HAVE BEEN THERE PRO.
ABOUT IDENTIFYING SOURCES
INCLUDING CONTRACTS IN PLACE TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE PPO THEY'LL BE AVAILABLE
FOR OUR CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM-
FIRST AND FOREMOST BUT ALSO-
WITH INTENTIONS OF MAKING IT
MORE BROADLY AVAILABLE AS THE
MARKET PLACE OPENS UP- UP WE
ARE. WE THROUGH THIS PROCESS-
WE- REMIND OF P. P. TO PRIVATE
HIGH. AND PRIVATE AS AS WELL AS
OTHERS THEY'RE ALL PART OF THIS
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT
PROTECTS ALL OF CALIFORNIA. SO
AS WE RECEIVED- SUPPLIES. WE%
RESPOND TO REQUESTS THAT WE
HAVE FROM CLINICS AND HOSPITALS
ACROSS THE STATE THERE IS A
SYSTEM THAT SET UP THAT ALLOWS
FOR REQUEST TO BE MADE- THROUGH
A REGIONAL- CONTACTS UP TO THE
STATE. AND WHEN WE RECEIVE THE
THOSE REQUESTS WE FILL THEM
ACCORDING. TO NEED AN
AVAILABILITY- CURRENTLY WE HAVE
AND NINETY FIVES- THAT OUR
NATIONAL PROVED AND THEY ARE
COMING IN- WE CONTINUED TO-
THEY THEY CONTINUE TO BE OUR-
LIMITED BUT ARE. AVAILABLE
GALLONS OF THE OTHER ONES THAT
HAVE BEEN A CHALLENGING IT FROM
GLOBAL SHORTAGES. BUT WE ALSO
HAVE THOSE IN WE ARE MOVING THE
MOUSE. AS THEY BECOME
AVAILABLE- AND THOSE SUPPLIES
ALSO ARE. AVAILABLE I'M GOING
IT WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT I IS THERE TO
PROTECT OUR CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. THANK YOU FOR THAT AND
RELATED TO HAT I DID REYES
WITH YOU YESTERDAY. CONCERNS
RAISED BY CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION ABOUT SOME NURSES.
BEING REQUIRED TO ENTER FROM.
CONTAMINATED AREAS OR WORK
AREAS WHO HAVE NOT BEEN
PROVIDED WITH ADEQUATE. PP I
KNOW I JUST RAISE THAT WITH YOU
YESTERDAY BUT. WOULD LIKE TO
HEAR. PART MEANT THREE BE AND
MAKE IT TO HIM. THE LEGAL ROUTE
TO PUT EMPLOYEE AND NOT TO PUT
IN SKINNER AND OTHERS AT RISK
BY PUTTING THEM IN A WORKPLACE
WITHOUT ADEQUATE. PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT. YES CENTER MAN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE CALL THAT WE
HAD YESTERDAY AND FOR YOU
SCHERING- THAT INFORMATION WITH
US WE ARE LOOKING INTO THAT ON
INDEED THERE IS GUIDANCE-
ONLINE FOR A CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM REGARDING- PP E. AND ITS
USE AND SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO
LOOK INTO THAT AND GET BACK TO
YOU. WITH FURTHER DETAILS ON
THAT IN RELATED TO THAT THANK
YOU I HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION
RELATED TO. NURSES AND OTHER
HEALTH CARE WORKERS WHO HAVE
TESTED POSITIVE FOR COVERT
NINETEEN- WHO OF DIED SOME
WHO'VE DIED FROM THE DISEASE.
BUT THERE'S NO DETAIL ON WHERE
THESE HEALTH CARE WORKERS
WORKED MORE THAN HOSPITALS
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES OR
OTHER FACILITIES. AND OTHER
THAN BEING CLASSIFIED AS HEALTH
CARE WORKER WAS THAT A DOCTOR
AND NURSE A RESPIRATORY
THERAPIST. IS IT POSSIBLE FOR
YOU TO GET. THAT MORE DETAILED.
INFORMATION WHILE PROTECTING
OBVIOUSLY PATIENT
CONFIDENTIALITY BUT IT WOULD
SEEM JUST THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF
WHO IS BEING EXPOSED AND- IN
THOSE SAID CASES WHERE SOMEBODY
HAS DIED. FOR US TO KNOW IF IT
WAS A DOCTOR AND NURSE OR
RESPIRATORY TH RESPIRATORY
THERAPISTS TO SEND INFORMATION
THAT YOU CAN GET FORCE. THE
CENTER MONNING AYE YOU ASKED ME
THAT QUESTION YESTERDAY AND I
DID CHECK WE DO NOT HAVE THE
SPECIFIC INFORMATION ABOUT
WHETHER THEY WERE A DOCTOR OR
NURSE IMMEDIATELY ON HAND- WE
HAVE INFORMATION ABOUT IT YOU
KNOW IF THEY WERE WORKING AND
SKILLED NURSING FACILITIES ARE
HOSPITALS. AND THAT INFORMATION
IS SOMETHING THAT WE CAN- WE
CAN LOOK MORE CLOSELY AT.
THANKS AND THEN JUST RELATED TO
THAT- SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ARE REQUIRED TO
REPORT. TO YOUR DEPARTMENT THE
NUMBER OF INFECTED HEALTHCARE
WORKERS IN THEIR FACILITIES AND
THE NUMBER WHO HAVE DIED
HOSPITAL'S HOWEVER ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO REPORT SIMILAR
INFORMATION. WHY IS THERE THAT
DISCREPANCY BETWEEN SKILLED
NURSING FACILITY REQUIRED
REPORTING AND WE'RE NOT GETTING
THAT INFORMATION FROM HOSPITALS.
I WILL HAVE TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THE SPECIFICS OF THAT. THANK
YOU AND I WOULD APPRECIATE THAT
MY NUMBER SOME OF THESE ARE
ISSUES THAT WERE JUST BROUGHT
TO YOUR ATTENTION YESTERDAY
THAT I WOULD VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE. THE FOLLOW UP.
SHIFTING AWAY FROM COVERT
NINETEEN WE DID DISCUSS. THE
CHALLENGE MAYBE PARTLY RELATED
TO COVERT NINETEEN OF. FAMILIES
NOT GETTING FACT CHILDREN
KEEPING ON THEIR VACCINATION
SCHEDULES- IN YOU SHARED WITH
ME AND I THINK WOULD BE OF
INTEREST TO THE COMMITTEE AND
THE PUBLIC QUITE STEPS YOU'RE
TAKING TO TRY TO PROTECT. OUR
VACCINE PROGRAMS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. IF YOU KNOW THE
VACCINATIONS ARE SO IMPORTANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR KIDS STAY
HEALTHY AND INDEED- SINCE-
COATED NINETEEN- SINCE WE HAVE
DECREASED ARE. A DURING THE
STAY AT HOME ORDERS IN ORDER TO
CREATE A MORE ACCESS TO CARE TO
PROTECT THE CARE SYSTEM WE
BACKED OFF ON SOME ELECTIVE
PROCEDURES AND SOME OUTPATIENT-
APPOINTMENTS AS WELL- AND WE
DID AN ANALYSIS IN APRIL AND WE
FOUND. THAT COMPARED WITH THE
LAST YEAR VACCINATIONS WERE
DOWN ABOUT 40% WHICH IS
INCREDIBLY CONCERNING TO US SO
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
THOUGHTFULLY THROUGH OUR CARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM MECHANISMS-
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO
IDENTIFY WAYS THAT WE CAN HELP
AND ENCOURAGE PROVIDERS TO
REACH OUT TO THOSE PATIENTS.
AND MAKE SURE THAT DAY THEY'RE
BROUGHT IN FOR THOSE
VACCINATIONS WE THINK THAT UP
PROVIDERS IN PARTICULAR ARE
YOUR TRUSTED. CONTACTS OF THESE
PATIENTS AND SO THEY'RE REALLY
GOOD MESSENGERS AND HELPING TO
COMMUNICATE AND GET UP PARENTS
TO BRING THEIR KIDS AND I
WANTED THE CLEAR MESSAGES THAT
I THINK WE TALKED ABOUT
YESTERDAY WAS THAT YOU KNOW OUR
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM IN OUR-
ENVIRONMENT JUST LIKE IN MANY.
DIFFERENT SECTORS IS CHANGE THE
WAY THAT WE'RE DOING WORK TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN PARENTS
BRING THEIR CHILDREN AND THEY
DON'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THERE
BEING HIGH RISK FOR THOSE
CHILDREN BE EXPOSED. NINETEEN
AS WELL SO WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE ALSO THAT THAT CASE NOT.
MAKE SURE. NO THAT THE BRING
THEIR CHILDREN AND THE WE NEED
THEM TO BE THE TO PROTECT THEIR
CHILDREN AND PROTECT THE
CHILDREN AROUND THEM WELL THANK
YOU AND THEN MY FINAL OCCUR
THAT I THINK IT WILL EVOLVING A-
WE HAD A GOOD ABOUT CHILL
HEALTH ABOUT. CHRONIC DISEASE.
DIE NEED. ACT SOME OF THE ON
LINE GOING. DETERMINANT IN.
HEALTH IN YEAR STRAW HISTORY
AND AREA IN YOUR CA. TO WORKING
US. IN THE LEGISLATURE. AS I
SHARED WITH YOU I THINK. THE
GOALS AND OBJECTIVES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ARE. SYNONYMOUS WITH THE GOALS
AND OBJECTIVES OF THE
LEGISLATURE WE ALL WANT A
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA. IN YET.
WE'VE SUFFERED SOME FRUSTRATION
IN OUR EFFORTS TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OVER THE YEARS- A
DEPARTMENT OF OVER. THREE
THOUSAND EIGHT HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES AND OVER TWO HUNDRED
PROGRAMS ONE OF MY QUESTIONS
WAS HOW DO YOU MANAGE SUCH A
MASSIVE ORGANIZATION. BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE SHOULD SEE
EACH OTHER AS ALLIES I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK YOU IN YOUR NEW
ROLE AS LEADER. TO WORK TO
IMPROVE. THE RESPONSE TIME OF
EMPLOYEES OF YOUR DEPARTMENT IN
CORY'S FROM MEMBERS OF THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND I'M JUST
GOING TO BE FRANK WE'VE BEEN
FRUSTRATED I SHARE THIS WITH
YOU YESTERDAY. OF ALL THE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES WE
DEAL WITH DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH HAS THE REPUTATION OF
NOT BEING RESPONSIVE TO MEMBERS
OF THE LEGISLATURE AND I WOULD
JUST LIKE YEAR COMMITMENT AS
THE NEW DIRECTOR. TO LOOK INTO
THAT IN AND COMMIT TO WORK WITH
THIS BECAUSE I THINK AT THE END
OF THE DAY. WHERE YOUR BEST
ALLIES TO ADVANCE GOOD POLICY
FOR THE PUBLIC THIS IS A
CALIFORNIA. SO THANK YOU.
THAT'S THAT'S COME TO HEAR AND
I IT FOR MY AND I KNOW ALSO FOR
A STAFF AND I THINK YOU AS A-
AGENCY WE HAVE LOTS OF
INFORMATION AND IT'S OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE A BILL TO
PROVIDE IT TO REALLY- MAKE SURE
THAT YOU HAVE THE INFORMATION
YOU NEED TO. IN YOUR ROLES AS
WELL AND SO I AM ABSOLUTELY
COMMITTED. PERSONALLY AND
WORKING WITH MY STAFF. TO MAKE
SURE THAT. WE CHANGE THE WAY
THAT WE DO WORK AND ENSURE THAT
YOU GET THE INFORMATION. ARE
YOU AND YOUR STAFF AND ALL OF
THE LEGISLATURE IT CAN RELY ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH. TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION THAT'S NEEDED IN A
TIMELY FASHION. THANK YOU
DOCTOR AND I DO APPRECIATE.
YOUR CANDOR AND IN RESPONSE TO
MY QUESTIONS TODAY AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO A GOOD WORKING
RELATIONSHIP MOVING FORWARD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
MONNING SENATOR BATES. I THINK
YOU AYE MADAM A CHAIR AND-
CONGRADULATIONS DOCTOR ANGEL I
THINK I'VE SEEN YOU. A LOT
BEFORE I'VE BEEN ABLE TO MEET
YOU. BY HAVING ALL BEEN ON MANY
CALLS FOR THAT YOU WERE-
CERTAINLY. AN ADVICE RON- AND
THANK YOU FOR JUMPING INTO THE
ARENA I HAD A VERY VERY
DIFFICULT TIME AND ONE THAT
PROBABLY DEFINE SO. THE ROLE OF
THE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER. IN
FINES OF MANY MANY PEOPLE
THROUGHOUT THE CHANNEL SIX. AND
ON YOU ENSURE. THAT TOPIC. AND
OUR- RESIDENTS IN THE NATION
ARE OLD. FEE BUT THERE IS ALSO
ONLY A LOT OF CONTROVERSY THEIR
ATTACHED. THAT AND YOUR ROLE I
AM SERVING OUR THING TO MADAM
TOWN. EIGHTY OF THE SPECIAL
COMMITTEE ON HAND. THE RESPONSE.
THERE ARE PRO TEMAS GIVEN A THE
A- TO LOOK AT WHAT WE DONE WELL
WELL WE HAVE DONE NOT SO WELL
AND WHY WE DO THE FEW. NO WHAT
KNOW NOW AND I AS SOON IT FROM
IN TIME. SOME OF THAT IN. WOULD
FINE IT SO INTO A LEDGER TO. SO
I'D LIKE TO ASK YOU GIVEN WHAT
WE KNOW NOW. WHAT WHAT ARE YOU
DOING AND WHAT IS THE STATE
DOING TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
BETTER PREPARED TO SPONSOR BUT
TO A SECOND WILL PAVE. OF COAL
SHOP FOR A NEW PANDEMIC BECAUSE
WE KNOW WHERE WE'VE HAD A
SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES WE'VE HAD
TESTING ISSUES. THAT WOULD BE
BROAD QUESTION. BUT I'M SURE
IT'S SOMETHING THAT MAYBE KEEPS
YOU UP AT NIGHT BUT IF YOU
COULD GIVE US. I NEVER JUST OF
A PEEKABOO ON FOR THOUGHT SAYS
YOU. KNOW WHAT ARE PER. HAVE
BEEN IN AND IT WILL SERVE BE
RECEIVED WELL BY THE COMMITTEE
AS WE PROVIDE A REPORT BACK. TO
THE LEGISLATURE. PROTON. SURE I
THINK IT. THE GOING INTO
PANDEMIC ARE WE IS THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT AND PUBLIC AND HAVE
BEEN FOR LIKE THIS FOR SOME
TIME BUT OF I IT'S WHEN YOU'RE
IN IT DID YOU WANT AND- BEST OF.
NAME THAT YOU. MAY NEED TO
CHANGE COURT. YOU'RE LEARNING A
NEW. IF MAYBE BEHAVE
DIFFERENTLY THAN ONE AND YOUR
COULD IN PLAY ALL OF PIECES TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS PROTECTED THAT'S
OUR ROLE. RESPONSIBILITY AND AS
WE MOVE FORWARD THROUGH THIS
PROCESS TO THE POINT WHERE WE
ARE NOW I CAN TELL YOU I FEEL
VERY CONFIDENT. ABOUT OUR STATE
POSITIONING RIGHT NOW. TO BE
ABLE TO RESPOND TO. COPE WITH
NINETEEN AND TO DO IT IN A WAY
THAT CAN PROTECT THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIANS I WILL ALSO
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS IS NOT OVER
AND- YOU'RE- YOUR QUESTION IS
AN IMPORTANT ONE BECAUSE- WHILE
WE THINGS ARE. IN STABLE AT
THIS TIME. RECOGNIZING ALSO
THERE'S A GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY
CERTAINLY AND VARIATION WITHIN
COUNTIES BUT OVERALL WE'RE IN A
VERY SOLID PLACE. WE HAVE. P.
P. R. CHAINS AND SUPPLY CHAINS
AND CONTRACTS IN PLACE. AB IS
COMING IN AT A SPEED THAT WERE
FEEL GOOD ABOUT AND IT WILL
ONLY BETTER MOVING FORWARD.
WITH TO OUR SPINDLES PROPER
FIRST. THEY DEMONSTRATED IN
WERE AMAZED CLASS AND PARTNERS
THAT THEY CAN REACT QUICKLY TO.
THAT SPACE WE CONTINUE TO. THE
AMOUNT OF THE EVENTS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE I SEE YOU BAD ACROSS
THE STATE WE CURRENTLY NOW HAVE
PROCESSES IN PLACE TO COLLECT
THAT DATA REGULARLY AND TO BE
ABLE TO UNDERSTAND IF THERE'S
ANY AREAS THAT WE SHOULD BE
PAYING CLOSER ATTENTION TO. THE
WE HAVE GREAT BUT A PROCESSES
IN PLACE TO REALLY UNDERSTAND
THE NEEDS OF OUR CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM GREAT PARTNERSHIPS IN
PLACE AND THE RESOURCES WE NEED
IN PLACE SHOULD WE NEED. TO
RESPOND BY MAKING MORE BEDS
AVAILABLE SO TO YOUR POINT IF
THERE IS A SURGE AND MORE BEDS
ARE AVAILABLE. WE ARE TRAINED
WHO WE KNOW HOW TO DO THIS AND
WE HAVE THE RESOURCES IN PLACE.
WE STILL AS A STATE THAT WE
NEED TO BE VERY THOUGHTFUL AND
VERY CAREFUL BECAUSE KOBE
NINETEEN AS A RISK AND EVERY
ONE OF US HAS A RESPONSIBILITY
IN MAKING SURE THAT WE REACHED.
THE TRANSMISSION ARE THESE AND
THAT'S BY MAKING THAT. WE YOU
WASH YOUR HANDS ARE WE WEAR
FACE COVERINGS WERE PUBLIC AND
IT REALLY IMPORTANT WE KEEP
SICKLE DISTANCE OTHERS. WITH A
YOU FOR THAT AND ONE YOU KNOW I
ALL THE MAY OF THE- ON REALLY
DO. TO GET SOME ANSWERS THAT
REALLY HELP YOU IN YOUR JOB AS
WE GO FORWARD. YOU KNOW WHERE
WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO ON
MAIENSCHEIN CERTAINLY THOSE
CRITICAL AREAS OF PP. AND
CERTAINLY- THE TESTING THE
TESTING ISSUE WAS A BIG ONE
CERTAINLY AND IN MY COUNTY IN
PARTICULAR BECAUSE WE HAVE
FEWER. PRIVATE LABS THAT
PARTICIPATED INITIALLY JUST HAD
THE PUBLIC LABS. A LAST
QUESTION GOES TO THE ISSUE OF
VACCINATION I HEARD ON A CALL
THIS MORNING. THAT THE STATE IS
ASKING FOR PARTICIPATION BY
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IT IS
STATEWIDE COMMITTEE TO
DETERMINE WHO WOULD BE. THE
FIRST PEOPLE TO RECEIVE VACCINE
NOW WHEN I HEARD WHEN IT'S
AVAILABLE AT THE END OF THIS
YEAR I WOULD SAY IF IT'S
AVAILABLE- BY FARLEY AND JOB. I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU HAVE SENT
OUT TO DIRECTIVE ASKING FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO MIGHT BE
INTERESTED IN PARTICIPATING IN
THAT COMMITTEE. AND THEY WOULD
BE CONSIDERING- WHO WOULD BE
OUR FIRST TO GET THE VACCINE OR
I GUESS WHO WOULD BE WILLING.
TO BE SOME OF THE FIRST TO GET
VACCINE IS THAT ACCURATE AND
JOHN THAT INFORMATION THAT'S
GOING TO BE. PROVIDED WITH MORE.
TO OF US WHO GET QUESTIONS
CERTAIN FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS.
WE ARE. PLAN IS TO AND THEY
ABOUT WHAT THAT MIGHT LIKE AND
HOW TO WE- THAT THE TYPES OF
THE- INTO. THAT WERE THAT OF
COMMITTEES IT COMMITTEE WOULD
NEED TO BE IN PLACE IN ORDER TO
RE THINK AND WEBER. ALL OF
CALIFORNIA AND ARE IN OUR NEW
TOWARD THAT PROCESS WE DO THINK
THAT- A VACCINE AT WE HAVE
HEARD ALSO- DIDN'T PERHAPS BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR I
APPRECIATE YOUR CAUTIOUS
pHOPE OR THE BEST AND WE
PREPARE FOR THE BEST BUT WE
ALSO REPAIR FOR- THE NEEDS IT
FOR THIS TO CARRY ON LONGER AND
SO I ALSO APPRECIATE VERY MUCH
THAT- REALISTIC- PERSPECTIVE
THAT YOU HAVE WITH RELATED.
RELATIONSHIP TO VACCINES AND WE
WILL MOST DEFINITELY KEEP YOU
ENGAGED IN A LIVE IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS. IT WILL BE VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO HAVE A
FRIEND INFORMATION JUST I ASK
MY COLLEAGUE GONNA. FINISH
MONEY MENTIONED YOU KNOW THE
VACCINATION ISSUES BEEN A BIG
ONE AND CERTAINLY AT WILL SAW
IT WILL SURROUND THE OFTEN I
UNDERSTAND THROUGH VACCINATION
WERE SEEKING HERD IMMUNITY. SO
JUST KEEP A FILE OF UP TO THE
MINUTE ON DOWN AND IF WE HAVE
ANY INFORMATION THAT WILL BE
HELPFUL TO YOU. A PLEASE REACH
OUT BECAUSE WE ARE GETTING ALL
IN MY TO COUNTY SAN DIEGO AND
ORANGE WE ARE GETTING OUR
WEEKLY WE ACTUALLY GOT TARA
THREE TIMES A WEEK UPDATES ON.
WHAT THE SITUATION LOOKED LIKE
ON ALL THE FRIENDS FOR COAL
VI<c.cyan> AND NOW IT'S USUALLY</c>
ONCE A WEEK AND IT'S VERY VERY
WELL DONE AND I KNOW THE STATE
IS DOING THAT TOO. BUT THE MORE
INFORMATION WE HAVE. OUR A AND
EDUCATION WE CAN PROVIDE I AM
AT THE LEVEL WILL BE CRITICAL.
TO ENSURE WHEN THE VACCINE IS
AVAILABLE THAT PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND JOB. IT IS. BUT WHAT
IS FOR. OFFERED ARE. SET WELL
WILL HOPEFULLY KEEP CONVERSE.
GOING MAKE IT VERY ARE. THANK
YOU A- THANK YOU FOR. UP OFFER
THIS EXTRA. OF UP. WE YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR BY LET ME TO
A BY STE MISTER WILK. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM. CONGRATS ON YOUR
POINT IN AND DAY YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE. JUST LIKE THE US WE
HAVE THE ROLE OF THE AND
CONSENT WHEN IT COMES TO COOPER
TRY UP. AND THIS COMMITTEE
MAKES RECOMMENDATION AND GOES
TO THE FLOOR OUR COLLEGE IN THE
FLOOR DON'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ASK THE QUESTIONS THEY HAVE
TO DO SIMPLY UP OR DOWN VOTE SO
I TOOK THE TIME TO REACH OUT
AND I'VE GOT A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS FROM
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE SO I
TRY TO DO IT IN ORDER TO MEET
SENSE BUT SOME PEOPLE THINK WE
DIDN'T DO ENOUGH SOME PEOPLE
THOUGHT WE DID TO ME SO I'M
JUST GOING TO PLOW THROUGH
THIS. AND GET YOUR A LOT. IT SO
MARCH SIXTEENTH THE VOTE TO JR
GET ON PRESS UNPRECEDENTED
POWER TO THE A TO GOVERNOR MANY
LEGISLATOR VOTED FOR THE
MEASURES PART DUE TO THE- THAT
YOU PROVIDE EARLIER THAT
AFTERNOON TO THE VARIOUS
CAUCUSES AS I RECALL FROM THE
BRIEFING YOU STATED COVER
NINETEEN WAS HIGHLY CONTAGIOUS
AND THAT WE SHOULD EXPECT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS TO BE INFECTED WE
WERE TOLD AMERICA MORTALITY
RATE WAS QUITE HIGH AND THAT WE
WOULD NOT BE SAFE UNTIL WE
REACHED HERD IMMUNITY AND OR A
VACCINE WAS DISCOVERED. SO IF
YOU CAN CRY THAT IF YOU WANT.
THIS IS MY- BUT SO HOW DO YOU
RECKON. CONSULT STATEMENTS FROM
MY SIXTEEN SO WHY IT WHAT HAS
HOW. YEAH I RECONCILE IT BY A
KNOWLEDGE IN GIVING CREDIT TO
ALL CALIFORNIANS- OUT MARCH
NINETEENTH AS YOU KNOW WE ARE.
YEAH I ISSUED A STAY AT HOME
ORDER WHICH MEANT STATS- UNLESS
PEOPLE HAD ESSENTIAL REASONS TO
GO OUT OF THEIR HOME LIKE TO GO
GROCERY SHOPPING OR TO PICK UP
PRESCRIPTIONS THEY WERE TO STAY
IN THEIR HOME UNLESS THEY WERE
PART OF THIS CENTURY WORKFORCE.
AND CALIFORNIA'S TOOK THAT
REALLY SERIOUSLY AND WE SAW WE
SAW THROUGH MOBILITY DATA
PEOPLE STOP TO GOING OUT DAIS
THE MOVEMENT ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SLOW DOWN AND
PEOPLE DID NOT GO OUT AND I
WOULD STATE HAS BEEN- SOMETHING
THAT CALIFORNIANS AND ALL OF US
CAN BE VERY PROUD OF BECAUSE WE
DID. SB OFF DAY BEND THE WRIST
THE PROJECT THAT YEAR DESCRIBE
WHERE THE PER. OF THAT EXIST
AND TO BECAUSE OF THIS WORK ON
THE PART OF HEALTH. WE'RE
LOOKING AT A VERY DIFFERENT
RIGHT NOW WITH RESPECT THAT
FIRST ANTICIPATED OUR- IN SPITE
THAT WE- THOUGHT THAT COULD IF
DIDN'T DO SOMETHING. AND IN
FACT WE SEEN WHAT HAVE ENOUGH
PLACES THE WORLD- I THEY DIDN'T
HAVE THE TYPE OF ORDER THAT WE
HAD IN PLACE EARLY AND OFTEN
DIDN'T SLOW. POPULATION
MOVEMENT DOWN SO THAT'S HOW I
WOULD RECONCILE THE TWO I WOULD
RECONCILE IT BY GIVING CREDIT
TO CALIFORNIANS I WOULD REMIND
US ALL THAT IT'S NOT OVER YET.
I'M WE'RE IN A POSITION NOW
WHERE- WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WATCH THE DATA AND THINGS ARE
VERY STABLE- BUT THAT IS
THAT'S- WHY WHERE WE ARE NOW IS
SO DIFFERENT FROM WHERE WE WERE
WHEN WE HAD THAT CONVERSATION
WITH YOU BACK. EARLIER IN MARCH
BREAK THE. KNWING WE KNOW. IN
THE CLASS DAMAGE AN FOR.
INFLICTED NOT SECOND. BUT
SOCIAL SO WHERE THERE'S MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES TO. A CHICKEN
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CHILD ABUSE
SUICIDE IN ALCOHOL AND DRUG
ADDICTION. FROM THE STATE HOME
ORDER. WOULD YOU RECOMMEND
CLOSING THE STATE AGAIN SHOULD
WE SEE AN INCREASE IN CASES.
AND IF SO WHAT WOULD BE THE
CRITERIA AND OR BENCHMARKS THAT
YOU WOULD USE TO DETERMINE
CLOSURE. SO WE HAVE PLAYED OUT
INDICATORS THAT WE ARE USING AT
THE STATE LEVEL TO HELP US
UNDERSTAND- BOTH PREPAREDNESS
OUR ABILITY TO RESPOND AND ALSO
TO FOLLOW. MEN OF INFECTION.
WITH A THE STATE OF. WE ARE.
THAT THE PROVISIONS THAT WE IN
PLACE SO FAR HAS BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR GETTING US TO
WHERE WE ARE NOW AND AS WE ARE
OPENING UP OUR ECONOMY AGAIN
AND AS WE CREATED THESE
PROCESSES OF VARIATIONS FOR.
COUNTIES ARE COUNTIES ALSO NOW
HAVE ASSUME TOO MUCH MORE
RESPONSIBILITY AND PREPAREDNESS
IN THEIR OWN RIGHT AND OUR OUR-
LEADING A LOT THOSE PROCESS
SEES AND FOLLOWING IN
MONITORING WHAT'S GOING ON THE
COMMUNITIES AND- PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS ARE MAKING THE
DECISIONS ABOUT THE SPEED
THAT'S APPROPRIATE I WOULD SAY
THAT WE ARE WE ARE ALL AT THE
STATE LEVEL AT THAT. COUNTY
LEVEL OUT BEING AT THE DATA ARE.
CONSTANTLY ASSESSING WHEN WE'RE
MAKE TO SAY ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
FOR OVER UP NEW AREAS ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT IT IS SAFE FOR
THOSE SIR. AND USE THE DATA TO
US UNDERSTAND WHETHER NOT A-
WOULD BE NEEDED EVERY. A CHANGE
IN OUR CASE. ARE WHEN YOU STAND
ALLIES WHERE THEY COMING FROM
AND UNDER IT TO A- WHAT KINDS
OF. WOULD BE A TO HELP CONTROL
THAT OUT. AS YOU KNOW WE
PUTTING CON TRACE AND HOPE. IN
PLACE AND TRAINING THEM WE I'VE-
REGISTERED. TRACERS SO THERE'S
ALL KINDS OF PREPAREDNESS
PIECES THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE
AND WILL BE USING THIS
INFORMATION TO HELP US. DECIDE
AT THE STATE LEVEL AND LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS WILL BE USING
THAT INFORMATION TO USE OF THE
LOCAL LEVEL TO UNDERSTAND IT'S
ANY TYPES OF ADDITIONAL-
CHANGES IN THE CURRENT- ORDERS
WOULD BE APPROPRIATE FOR THEM.
THANK YOU. YEAH KNOWING WHAT WE
KNOW NOW WOULD WE HAVE BEEN
BETTER OFF ESTABLISHING SOCIAL
DISTANCING STANDARDS AND
QUARANTINING THOSE THAT WE KNEW
WERE MOST VULNERABLE THE
ELDERLY AND THOSE WITH
UNDERLYING HEALTH ISSUES SWEDEN
DID. THEN ORDERING THIS AT HOME
ORDER. SO YOU KNOW WE EARLY ON
OUR STATE HOME ORDER INCLUDED
VARIES A CLEAR LANGUAGE THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE OLDER- HAVE
COMORBIDITIES SHOULD SHOULD
STAY AT HOME AND THAT PROVISION
HAD STAYS HAS STAYED IN PLACE
EVEN WITH THE GRADUAL LIFTING
OF OUR STAY AT HOME ORDERS OUR
STATE HOME ORDERS ARE PUT IN
PLACE HOWEVER AT THAT TIME
BECAUSE THERE WAS TOO MUCH
POPULATION MOVE. WE WERE SEEING
THE GROWTH AND NEXT WILL GROW
THICKER IS STARTING TO GO IN
THAT THAT WE KNOW IN
EPIDEMIOLOGY SHOWS THAT YOU ARE
AT YOUR HAVING A RATE THAT THAT
REQUIRES ACTION AND SO YOU KNOW
I FEEL LOOKING BACK AT WHERE WE
WERE AND THE ACTION THAT WE
TOOK THAT IT WAS THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. AT THE TIME WE ARE
AND I AM STILL BELIEVE THAT IT
WAS IT IS THE RIGHT THING I
THAT WE DID ALSO. THANK YOU
WHAT A MOVE ON TO SEE TO THE IS
FROM ONE OF MY LOCAL BOARD.
DAVE NOW SENATE TO PRINT SIR.
IN BEING GETTING INTO FROM THE-
AND 50% 50% OF PARENTS WHAT
THEIR THEIR CHILDREN BACK IN
SCHOOL AND 50% DON'T. AND ABOUT
15% SAY THEIR CHILDREN ARE NOT
COMING BACK TO PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
SO MY QUESTION I GUESS WOULD BE
WHAT QUESTIONS IN DATA SHOULD
FAMILIES CONSIDER ON WHETHER TO
SEND THEIR CHILDREN BACK TO
SCHOOL. SO I UNDERSTAND THIS IS
A VIRUS THAT IS NEW TO US AND
THINGS THAT ARE NEW. AND COME
WITH UNKNOWNS- CAN LEAVE PEOPLE
FEELING A LITTLE BIT. SCARED
SOMETIMES AND ALSO ANXIOUS AND
I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT
THING DURING THIS TIME PERIOD
IS TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE AS MUCH INFORMATION AS
THEY NEED TO MAKE THAT THAT
BEST DECISIONS FOR THEM AND FOR
THEIR CHILDREN I WILL TELL YOU
THAT OVER THE YOU KNOW WE
RELEASED A GUIDANCE. FOR THE
WAYS IN WHICH SCHOOLS WILL BE
REORGANIZED TO AT- TO HELP
REDUCE THE RISK OF INFECTION
AND OVER THE COMING WEEKS
BEFORE SCHOOLS OPEN IT WILL BE
LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PARENTS TO SPEAK IN PARTICULAR
WITH. WTH THEIR- LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS AND THEIR
SCHOOL SYSTEMS TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT CHANGES WERE PUT IN PLACE
AND TO THINK VERY CLEARLY
ABOUT. ABOUT A WHAT'S BEST FOR
THEIR CHILDREN BUT I WILL TELL
YOU THAT THAT GUY THAT WE PUT
IN PLACE AB IN. AND I AND IT IS
THERE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE TAX
THE AND WEALTHY OF ARCH. AND
OUR AND- WOULD NOT BE. AND TING
IT WOULD THINK THAT WE WERE AT
THE RIGHT TIME COMES OF THE
MOVEMENT OF CODE NINETY. TO
CREATE. SCHOOL AND. THE WAY IT
WOULD REDUCE THE FOR COVER
NINETEEN AND AS WE HAVE. SO WHO
IS GOING TO MONITOR AND ENFORCE
THAT- ELEAZAR ACTUALLY PERFORM
THE DUTIES THAT ARE THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN THE GUIDELINES. I
DID ALL OF THIS HAPPENS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL- AND THE DETAILS OF
THAT I DON'T HAVE FOR YOU BUT I
CERTAINLY CAN GET BACK TO YOU
WITH THEM OKAY GREAT THANK YOU.
MOM WHAT GUIDANCE IS BEING
GIVEN AS FAR AS IN INSURING
MITIGATION PLANS ARE IN PLACE
AT A STUDENT STAFF MEMBER
TEACHER OR RELATED FAMILY
MEMBER TEST POSITIVE FOR KOBE
NINETEEN. SO ALL OF THAT
GUIDANCE IS B. IS BEING
DEVELOPED IN THE SCHOOL
ENVIRONMENT WE ALSO HAVE IT FOR
THE WORK ENVIRONMENT AND IT
INCLUDES- INFORMATION IN THERE
THAT YOU'LL SEE ABOUT. IF
SOMEBODY TEST POSITIVE- TO
EVALUATE AND ASSESS CLOSE
CONTACTS OF THAT INDIVIDUAL
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THAT INDIVIDUAL SHOULD BE.
WARRANTY AND IF THERE. OUR
CONTACT OR OR ISOLATED IT- IF%
THEY'RE POSITIVE AND- AND THEN
THE KIND OF DISINFECTING THAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN THE SCHOOLS
AS WELL SO ALL OF THAT IS
CLEARLY OUTLINED IN THERE AND
IS VERY CRITICAL LAST THANK YOU
MOVE ON TO A COUPLE OF THE
BUSINESS QUESTIONS SO I KNOW
YOU'RE YOU'RE LOOKING AT THIS
LIKE IT YOU KNOW MADE A DATA
AND ALL THAT WE'RE ALL ON THE
FRONT LINES DEALING WITH.
PEOPLE AND I CANNOT TELL YOU
HOW MANY TIMES I CONVERSATION
AS WITH GROWN SUCCESSFUL MAN
CRYING. BECAUSE THEY WERE THEY
WERE LOSING THEIR BUSINESS. AND
A LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE THAN
PEOPLE THAT HAVE INFORMATION
SELECT PEOPLE WHO KNEW ME SO I
HAD SITUATIONS WHERE AT CAR
DEALERSHIPS. THE LOCAL THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE LOCAL OWNERS WHO
KNEW ME. FOR CLOTHES BECAUSE
THEY KNEW THEY HAD TO CLOSE AND
RIGHT ACROSS THE STREET IS SOME
YOU KNOW CORPORATE. CAR
DEALERSHIP THAT YOU KNOW
THEY'RE HEADQUARTERED IN
FLORIDA AND THEY'RE OPEN.
BECAUSE A LOT OF FRUSTRATION
AND I DON'T REALLY BLAME THAT
ON ANYBODY BECAUSE THIS WAS ALL
NEW TO US. BUT BUSH'S THIS
LOCAL BUSINESSES BEGIN TO RE
OPEN THAT THEY WANT TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS EXPECTED OF
THEM AND DO WHAT IS SAFE FOR
THEIR EMPLOYEES AND CUSTOMERS
IN MANY CASES THERE'S OVERLAP
IN FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BUSINESSES
NERVOUS ABOUT BEING ABLE TO
COMPLY ESPECIALLY CAN INCIDENTS
WHERE THE BAKER I CLEAR
DIRECTIVES SO HOW WAS THE
DEPARTMENT COORDINATING WITH
LOCAL COUNTY INSPECTORS THANK
YOU KIDDING WITH BUSINESS WHEN
THERE IS A JURISDICTIONAL
OVERLAP. STILL IN THE STATE
LEVEL WE PUT OUT GUIDANCE FOR
SECTORS AS THEIR RE OPENING AND
THAT IS POSTED ONLINE THAT
PROVIDES INFORMATION ABOUT WHAT
KINDS OF MODIFICATIONS SHOULD
BE MADE FOR A SECTOR TO OPEN.
ULTIMATELY THE LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER THOUGH IS THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO JUST SA IT
MAKES THE DECISION ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT IT IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THAT SECTOR TO
BE OPENED IN THAT. BECAUSE THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER HAS THE
BEST INFORMATION ABOUT THE
MOVEMENT OF DISEASES THAT
COMMUNITY UNDERSTANDS BEST
WHETHER OR NOT. THE RIGHT
MOMENT FOR THEM SO THAT
DECISION IS REALLY BEING MADE
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. NOW IF
THERE'S OTHER QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE JURISDICTIONAL- DECISION
MAKING I THINK IT WOULD PERHAPS
VERY IF THERE'S SPECIFIC
SECTORS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT AND I CAN GET BACK TO YOU
ON THE DETAILS OF THAT BUT IN%
GENERAL THAT'S THE WAY THE
SECTOR DECISIONS ARE MADE ON
THE RESPONSIBILITIES MCCARTY.
THANK YOU. NOW THE STATUS GIVEN
APPROVAL FOR AMUSEMENT PARKS TO
OPEN- BEGINNING JULY
SEVENTEENTH. YET ARE WONDERFUL-
COUNTY STATE FAIRS WHICH HAVE A
LARGE YOUTH EDUCATIONAL
COMPONENT TO THEIR PROGRAMMING.
ARE STILL WAITING FOR
GUIDELINES TO BE ISSUE. DO YOU
HAVE ANY IDEA WELL WHEN THOSE
MIGHT OCCUR. SO I DON'T HAVE SO
WHEN WE MAKE DECISIONS IS
REALLY FOLLOWING THE DAY SO I
ALSO- THE DATE THAT YOU HAVE
ABOUT- PARKS OPENING AND OTHERS
WE WILL NEED TO CONFIRM ALL OF
THAT- AND WE DON'T HAVE A
SPECIFIC DATE. OUT OUTSIDE FOR
THESE OTHER SECTORS RIGHT NOW
WE'RE FOLLOWING THE DATA AND
HAS IT BECOMES AS WE RECOGNIZE.
THAT DIFFERENT SECTORS ARE
READY TO OPEN AND THEN WE'LL
MAKE THAT INFORMATION
AVAILABLE. SO WHAT'S THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A FAIR IN
LET'S SAY MAGIC MOUNTAIN OR
DISNEY LAND. YEAH SO THE
GUIDANCE FOR- FOR- PARKS TO
OPEN HAS NOT BEEN RELEASED YET
OKAY I THOUGHT IT WAS ALL RIGHT.
OKAY VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
MOVING ON THIS IS FROM NUMBER
QUESTIONS FROM AND ANOTHER
SENATOR SO- WHY ARE WE NOT
DOING REGULAR SCIENTIFICALLY
MONITOR TESTS ARE RANDOM
SAMPLES OF THE POPULATION TO
SHOW THE EXTENT OF A
SYMPTOMATIC INFECTIONS OVER ON
SECTIONS AND THE RATE OF SPREAD.
SO THIS IS A FUNDAMENTAL PUBLIC
HEALTH PRACTICE TO DO
SURVEILLANCE TO UNDERSTAND THE
SPREAD OF DISEASE ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CHALLENGES WE'VE HAD
OUR- IN GAME CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES HAS
BEEN VERY LIMITED SUPPLIES AND
LACK OF ACCESS TO TESTING. SO
CALIFORNIA THAT WAS VERY
PROACTIVE CREATING A TESTING
TASK FORCE WHICH HAS WORKED
AGGRESSIVELY THROUGH PRIVATE
PART OF PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIPS WORKING WITH OUR-
ACADEMIC PARTNERS AS WELL TO
REALLY RAMP UP TESTING AND
TODAY WE ARE AT OUR GOAL AND WE
CONTINUE TO INCREASE WERE OVER
SIXTY THOUSAND. TEST THE DAY
WHICH IS WHERE WE NEED TO BE WE
NEEDED TO HAVE ADEQUATE TESTING
HOWEVER TO SERVE THE NEEDS OF
PEOPLE WHO NEEDED THE
INFORMATION FOR A MEDICAL
DECISION MAKING AND ALSO WE
PRIORITIZED FRONT LINE HEALTH
CARE WORKERS. AND OTHERS AROUND
CONCRETE SETTINGS ON IT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE WHO ARE AT
GREATEST RISK WOULD BE
PROTECTED SO THAT IS WHERE WE
HAVE TARGETED OUR TESTING TO
DATE. AS HAS BECOME MORE
AVAILABLE WE ARE PUTTING IN
PLACE SURVEILLANCE SYSTEMS JUST
TO WHAT YOU ARE SPEAKING TO
THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
UNDERSTAND BETTER THE SPREAD OF
DISEASE ACROSS THE STATE. GOOD
IDEA OF WHERE I CLOSE NINETY
THE HIGH SPOTS ARE BECAUSE OF
WHEN THERE IS- TESTING NEEDED.
A FAIR AMOUNT OF TESTING GETS
DONE AND WE UNDERSTAND THE
LEVEL AND SO FOR EXAMPLE WE'VE
BEEN CUT FOLLOWING- THE TEST
POSITIVITY WHICH HELPS US
UNDERSTAND. THE KEEPING KEEPING
IN MIND ALSO THE LEVEL OF
TESTING. THAT THE RATE OF-
CASES IN A COUNTY AND THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO US AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AND STATE LEVEL
AND WILL BE MOVING FORWARD AND
YOU'LL HEAR MORE. FROM US- IN
IN THE IN THEIR NEW YOU'RE NEAR
FUTURE ABOUT SURVEILLANCE AND-
MORE INFORMATION THA WILL BE
COMING AS TESTING BECOMES MORE
BROADLY IS AVAILABLE GREAT
THANK YOU. I NURSING HOMES
VULNERABILITIES HAVE BEEN KNOWN
FOR MONTHS DESPITE THING THAT
THEY ARE PRIORITY FOR TESTING
WHERE WE ARE TESTING EVERY
RESIDENTS STEP PERSON ON A
REGULAR BASIS. SO IT OF IT IS
BECAUSE OF THE- PRIOR VERY
LIMITED TESTING- CAPACITY THAT
WE HAD BUT WE ACTUALLY HAVE PUT
IN PLACE NOW POLICIES. FOR
TESTING EVERY INDIVIDUAL IN
EVERY IN NOT. ILL NURSING
FACILITY THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO BASELINE
TESTING. IT HAS BEEN- I.
REQUIRED IN THAT AND ALSO THESE
LETTER WHICH GOES OUT TO-
LICENSED FACILITIES THAT THEY
WILL BE DOING TESTING NOT ONLY
OF EVERY RESIDENT BUT ALSO- THE
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AS WELL AND
THEN THERE IS A MECHANISM IS
PUT IN PLACE IF A POSITIVE TEST
IS FOUND WHAT THE HELL OFTEN
REPEATING- TEST WILL NEED TO BE
DONE. AND IF I'M- IF NO CASES
ARE FOUND. THEY WILL ALSO HAVE
TO CONTINUE. TESTING SUBSETS OF
THOSE EMPLOYEES. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE NO NEW CASES
INTRODUCED SO WE ARE ON A PATH
RIGHT NOW WE'RE MOVING
AGGRESSIVELY THROUGH THIS AND
WE REALLY DO BELIEVE THAT
TESTING IS ESSENTIAL IN THOSE
ENVIRONMENTS AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE READ DIRECTING A LOT OF
OUR TESTING RESOURCES RIGHT
NOW. GREAT THANK YOU ARE
DELIVERING THE INSTRUCTION RATE
REMAIN THE TOP STATE GOAL OR
HAS BEEN REALLY REPLACE WITH
THE DESIRE TO RE OPEN THE
ECONOMY EVEN IF THE INFECTION
RATES GO UP. IF SO HOW HIGHER
RATE WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE. SO WE
HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE SINCE WE
STARTED OPENING SECTORS THAT
ASK PEOPLE MOVE MORE MORE
PEOPLE WILL GET INFECTED WHICH
ALSO MEANS OUR CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. HAS TO BE ON THE READY
AND IT ALSO MEANS THAT ARE
CONTINUING MONITORING OF THE
CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM AND THE
NUMBER OF. PATIENTS THAT ARE
ADMITTED NAY NUMBER OF
INDIVIDUALS AND I SEE YOU
CONTINUES. A DAILY ALONG WITH
ALL OF THE OTHER A MONITORING-
THAT WE'RE DOING. THERE IS NOT
A SET NUMBER OF SOME LEVEL OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT IT'S OKAY TO
BE INFECTED THAT'S NOT A WAY TO
DO PUBLIC HEALTH IT'S NOT A
WAY. TO MAKE PUBLIC HEALTH
DECISIONS BUT IT IS. QUESTION
MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT SECTORS
RE OPENING SO THAT PEOPLE CAN
CONTINUE TO MOVE THAT PERSONAL
RESPONSIBILITY IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THAT WHEN YOUR OUT
YOU USED TO FACE COVERINGS WHEN
YOU'RE A PUBLIC THAT YOU KEEP
THAT DISTANCE THEN THAT YOU
WASH YOUR HANDS FREQUENTLY IS
REALLY GOING TO BE THE THING
THAT ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO TAKE
CONTROL ABOUT. THEIR LEVEL OF
RISK- EVERY DAY WHEN THEY AKE
A DECISION ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT
LEAVE THE HOUSE. FURTHERMORE IN
OUR WORK ENVIRONMENT THE
GUIDANCE THAT WE'VE PUT OUT
IT'S ALSO BEEN CREATED IN A
WAY. THAT WOULD HELP REDUCE THE
RISK FOR COVERT NINETEEN BUT AS
WE MOVE MORE THE RISK WILL.
CONTINUE TO BE THERE AND SO WE
ARE ON THE READY IN CASE HERE
ARE MORE CASES TO BE ABLE TO
DETECT THEM AND ALSO TO RESPOND
WITH OUR CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM.
THANK YOU THIS KIND OF A RANDOM
QUESTION BUT I'M JUST CURIOUS.
NINETY FIVE MASS TO THE
COMPARED. NINETY FIVE MASS
BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THERE'S A LOT MORE SOURCES. OF
CAYENNE NINETY FIVE SO.
BASICALLY THAT OPEN ENDED FOR
YOU. YEAH THAT'S A VERY
TECHNICAL QUESTION THAT I'LL
NEED TO GET BACK TO YOU ON BUT
IT CERTAINLY RELATES TO LIKE
THE FIT AND APPROVAL- OF THOSE
OF THOSE NOW. WE'RE GETTING
NEAR THE END I AND I APOLOGIZE
TO EVERYBODY BUT- THESE ARE
QUESTIONS THAT SENATORS YOU
KNOW WANTED ASKS AND WHEN I'M
HAPPY TO BE THEIR VOICE. SO YOU
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT- ON
MARCH NINETEENTH AND I KNOW I
WAS CAUGHT OFF GUARD I WAS
WATCHING EVERYTHING ON TV WHEN
THE GOVERNOR ANNOUNCED A- YOU
KNOW. THE STATE HOME ORDER. AND
AS WE'VE GONE ALONG ALSO I KNOW
THESE YOU KNOW THESE DIFFERENT
OPENING UP TO WHATEVER HAPPENS.
SO CAN YOU WALK ME THROUGH THE
PROCESS I MEAN OBVIOUSLY HE'S
HE'S THE FINAL DETERMINANT ON
THAT BUT- IS THERE SOMETHING
WHERE. YOU DECIDED YOU YOU TELL
HAMMERS- TEAM OR- HOW DO YOU
HOW DO YOU MAKE THOSE
DETERMINATIONS AND WHO
ULTIMATELY BESIDES THE GOVERNOR
HAS THE FINAL CALL. I'M SORRY
SENATOR YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THE STAY HOME ORDER YES. AND
YOU MENTIONED EARLIER THAT YOU
THE ONE THAT MADE THE CALL IN
THE NINETEENTH AND SO AS WE'VE
PROGRESSED. WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
PROCESS FOR DETERMINING HOW WE
OPEN UP. OKAY SO AS SO- AS THE
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
AND- I AM THE ONE THAT WRITES
THE ORDERED TO STAY HOME ORDER
AND AS IT GETS MODIFIED THOSE
MODIFICATIONS NEED TO BE
CHANGED. I NEED TO. PUT OUT A
NEW ORDER IF IT'S DIFFERENT
THAN THE EXISTING ORDER SO
WHILE I DO SIGN THE ORDER AS A
DIRECTOR OF THE- CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH AND
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER.
THAT DECISION IS MADE- BASED
UPON OUR- THE LA CONVERSATIONS
WITH EXPERTS ACROSS MY
DEPARTMENTS- WE ARE LOOKING AT
THE DATA AND- WE'RE TALKING-
NOT ONLY AMONGST OURSELVES BUT
WE ARE ALSO WORKING. THROUGH
OUR AGENCY WITH SECRETARY
DOLLY. WE ARE HAVING A
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE CENTERS
FOR DISEASE CONTROL WE'RE WE'RE
INTEGRATING ALL OF THE DATA
THAT WE HAVE TO MAKE THE BEST
DECISION- WHILE I SIGNED THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFF. ORDER OF
COURSE IT IS. AS THE DIRECTOR
OF A TECHNICAL AGENCY I IN
GIVING TECHNICAL ADVICE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S FOR HIS ULTIMATE
DECISION MATING MAKING AS USE
INTEGRATING INFORMATION ACROSS
ALL OF GOVERNMENT BUT I'M
PROVIDING A TECHNICAL
RECOMMENDATION. FOR OUT FOR AN
OR IN THE CASE OF THE STATE
HOME ORDER THAT A STAY IN ORDER
WOULD BE RECOMMENDED AND THEN
ULTIMATELY. THAT DECISION IS
MADE I DO I AM THE ONE THAT
SIGNED IN TERMS OF THE DISK.
THAT YOU. ARE MOVING FORWARD
IT'S VERY MUCH THE SAME PROCESS
WE HAVE COMMITTED TO ANCHORING
OUR DECISIONS BASED UPON THE
DATA WE SHARED WITH YOUR SIX
INDICATORS THAT WE USE GOING
FORWARD TO UNDERSTAND THE
STABILITY. OF ARE CARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. THE AMOUNT OF
PREPARATION AND PREPAREDNESS WE
HAVE ACROSS THE STATE- BROADLY
AND THEN ALSO IT COUNTY LEVELS
WERE ALSO WATCHING THAT VERY
CAREFULLY AND SO THOSE
DECISIONS ARE ALL MADE BY
INTEGRATING THE DATA AND
THINKING. ABOUT A FIRST AS WE
ROLLED OUT OR AS WE DESCRIBED
IN OUR PANDEMIC ROAD MAP. THAT
THE DIFFERENT STAGES THAT FIRST
PHASE IS THE FIRST LOOK AT
LOWER RISK- WORK ENVIRONMENT
DOES WORK ENVIRONMENTS THAT
WITH MODIFICATION- COULD OPEN
EARLIER AND THEN WE'VE BEEN
BUILDING OUT TO THOSE THAT MAY
BE- MORE RISKY MORE RISKY
BECAUSE THEY RE IN. SALT IF.
POPULATION AND SO AGAIN THAT
INFORMATION IS BEING USED AND
SYNTHESIZED OUT TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS USING THE BEST
EVIDENCE THAT WE HAVE FOR
KEEPING CALIFORNIANS HEALTHY
GREAT THANK YOU FINAL. I WANT
TO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL
THE TIME YOU USE USE THAT SPENT
WITH US TODAY I DO WANT TO
SHOOT A FINAL QUESTION- CENTER
BASE TO TALK EARLY ON ABOUT YOU
KNOW A VACCINE AND NOT ME I.
WORK HEARING ALL THESE TIME
LINES AND THEY SEEM VERY-
AMBITIOUS TO ME BUT DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE TO HAVE A
WORKING VACCINE IN PLACE BEFORE
WE CAN COMPLETELY OPEN UP
CALIFORNIA. YOU KNOW I THINK.
PART OF THIS IS THAT WE MUST
HAVE TREATMENT AND THERAPY AT A
MINIMUM TO BE ABLE TO- TO BE
ABLE TO. EAT AT. I MEAN STEP
WISE PROCESS RIGHT SO. SO AT
THIS TIME THE TREATMENTS THAT
WE HAVE REALLY ARE. VERY
LIMITED. AND THEY ARE FOCUSED
ON WHEN PEOPLE ARE VERY SICK.
SO AS MORE TREATMENTS
POTENTIALLY BECOME AVAILABLE
THAT MIGHT BE YEARS EARLIER-
MIGHT EVEN BE USED FOR A
SYMPTOMATIC PEOPLE THERE MIGHT
BE DIFFERENT WAYS THAT WE CAN
THINK ABOUT HOW MEDICAL
TREATMENTS. A MEDICAL
INTERVENTIONS BE THE VACCINE
OR- TREATMENTS. MAY PROVIDE US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO- TO. TO OPEN
UP OR MAKE DECISIONS A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY. WE CAN'T. WHEN IT
HAPPENED- BUT WE HAVE BEEN VERY
CLEAR FROM THE BEGINNING THAT
AS LONG AS A LARGE POPULATION
IN CALIFORNIA. REMAINS THE
VULNERABLE TO THIS VIRUS. ARE
RETURNING TO WAIT THE WAY IT
WAS BEFORE WILL BE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT AND UNLIKELY. ARE
REALLY YOUR ANSWERS IN YOUR
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WELCOME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN LET ME GO
TO SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU
MAYOR PRO TEM. DOCTOR GOOD
AFTERNOON AFTERNOON DISAPPEARED
FROM MY SCREEN I KNOW I I'M
HAVING THE SAME- I CAN'T SEE
YOU EITHER I'M SEARCHING. NO NO
YOU DISAPPEARED AGAIN I. WELL
ONE THOUGH SO WE CAN CONTINUE I
WAS GOING TO SAY
CONGRATULATIONS BUT HAVING.
SITTING HERE FOR A WHILE I
THINK CONDOLENCES MIGHT BE IN
ORDER. BUT WE ARE VERY LUCKY TO
HAVE YOU AND I THINK YOU. YOU
DESERVE NOT TO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR ME SO LET ME JUST
MAKE ONE ONE COMMENT YOU KNOW
THERE'S CERTAIN ASPECTS OF OUR
ECONOMY AND OUR SOCIETY. THAT
DON'T. TURN ON WITH A LIGHT
SWITCH THEN I REALIZE IT'S
DIFFICULT TO PLAN WITH THIS
COVERT NINETEEN. BUT IN THE
FUTURE WHEN WE ARE ABLE TO HAVE
A LITTLE BIT MORE
PREDICTABILITY WHEN IT COMES TO
CONVENTIONS AND CONVENTION
CENTERS OR EVEN OUR-
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. IF AT SOME POINT YOU
CAN AS A DEPARTMENT AND
CALIFORNIA'S THE STATE CAN
PROVIDE TARGET DATES FOR RE
OPENING I THINK THAT WOULD BE
VALUABLE. IN TERMS OF
PREDICTABILITY AND ALLOWING
THESE INSTITUTIONS WHETHER IT'S
A VISITORS AND CONVENTION
CENTER OR WORK WHETHER IT'S A
COLLEGE OR UNIVERSITY BUT TO
BEGIN TO PLAN TO BRING PEOPLE
BACK TO THAT PARTICULAR OF
VENUE WHERE THAT PARTICULAR
FORUM SO. I JUST WANT TO TELL
YOU HOW APPRECIATIVE I AM OF
THE THOUGHTFUL WAY THAT YOU AND
THE GOVERNOR AND THE
ADMINISTRATION HAVE BEEN
ROLLING OUT OF THE RE OPENING-
I APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU
HAVE THE STICK. AND YOU'RE
TAKING CARE OF US AND PAYING
ATTENTION TO OUR HEALTH AND
SAFETY SO WITH THAT I HAVE NO
QUESTIONS AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
MOVING YOUR CONFIRMATION AT THE
APPROPRIATE POINT IN TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR ROTH AYE AND- YEAH
I YOU GOTTA FIGURE WHICH SCREEN
TO LOOK AT- SO I ALSO WANT TO
ADD MY CONGRATULATIONS ODD
NOTICING THAT YOU WERE HERE
PROBABLY ABOUT FIVE MONTHS OF A
WHEN WE EXPERIENCE MID MARCH
AND- THE PANDEMIC IN FRONT OF
US. I HOPE IT ALLOWED YOU TO
GET YOUR BEARINGS BEFORE YOU
HAD TO SHIFT INTO SUPER HIGH
GEAR- I THINK MY COLLEAGUES OF
ASK ALMOST ANY QUESTION I COULD.
I ACTUALLY. AS FACILITATOR
CHAIR IT MAKES MY JOB EASIER I
ONLY HAVE ONE LAST AUDIT TOPIC
AND I KNOW THAT IT'S SOMETHING
YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH BECAUSE
THERE WAS FEEDBACK I TO THE
ADMINISTRATION AND I KNOW HAT
I'VE HEARD THE GOVERNOR COMMENT
ON IT BUT- EARLY ON- IN EARLY
OR WILL MARCH SOON AFTER MY
COLLEAGUES AND I WENT HOME OUR
AND RECESSED. I GOT A COUPLE OF
ARTICLES FOR MEMBERS OF MY
COMMUNITY FROM THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY AND THEY WERE SAYING
TO ME THAT ARE MEMBERS OF MY
COMMUNITY WERE AT HIGHER RISK
OF CODE NINETEEN WILL OF COURSE
I AM I DON'T HAVE THAT DATA SO
I HAD MY HI HEALTH STAFF
CONTACT THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND IN FACT THEY
TOLD US NO THEY THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE- IT I BELIEVE AND GO
INTO THE DATA AND THE ARE THE
EXPERTS. BUT I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT- NOT KEEPING THE DATA AS
IT RELATES TO LGBT Q. NON
BINARY- INDIVIDUALS ALTHOUGH I
RECOGNIZE THE DIFFICULTY- AS
YOU ARE IN CAN BRING SOMETHING
THAT WE DIDN'T ANTICIPATE A
PANDEMIC THAT BECAME VERY. OUR
EVIDENT VERY QUICKLY THAT WE
OBVIOUSLY HAD A REAL PROBLEM.
BUT ARE SO HOW YOU'RE PREPARED
TO COLLECT DATA AND DO THAT BUT-
YOU KNOW FROM HISTORY ARE THOSE
FROM OUR MARGINALIZE MINORITY
ETHNIC COMMUNITIES AS WELL AS
GENDER. HISTORICALLY WOMEN.
HAVE BEEN LEFT OUT OF THE DATA
AND THE STUDIES AND THE NUMBER
SO IT'S VERY HARD FOR US TO.
DRAW ANY CONCLUSIONS FROM THAT
SO I JUST KIND OF WOULD LIKE
YOU TO RESPOND TO THE- ISSUE OF
LGBT Q. OUR DATA RELATED TO THE
NUMBERS OF COVERT NINETEEN. AND
ALSO AT MOVING FORWARD I HAD A
WE INTEND TO. ADDRESS THAT
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES. YEAH A LOOK AT- WE
WON'T UNDERSTAND HOW TO RESPOND
TO HEALTH INEQUITIES OF WE'RE
NOT MEASURING THEM WE WON'T
FIND THEM SO WHAT WE DON'T
COLLECT IS AS IMPORTANT AS WHAT
WE DO COLLECT. AND WHEN WE SEE
GAPS WE NEED TO BE PROACTIVE
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WE
DEVELOP MECHANISMS TO BE ABLE
TO COLLECT THAT DATA TO
UNDERSTAND IT AND I THINK WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LGBT Q.
MORE TALK ABOUT RACE ETHNICITY
WHEN WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THESE
THINGS THAT WE KNOW ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO OUR COMMUNITY OUR-
STATE VALUES THESE ARE AREAS
THAT WE NEED TO LOOK. VERY
CLOSELY AT SO I CAN TELL YOU
I'M COMMITTED MY DEPARTMENT IS
COMMITTED TO LOOKING ACROSS-
OUR DATA SOURCES AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT. WHERE DATA
IS BEING COLLECTED AND WHEN
IT'S NOT ON HOW CAN WE AND IF
IT'S POSSIBLE. TO ADDRESS THOSE
GAPS- WHEN IT COMES TO- SEXUAL
ORIENTATION AND GENDER I.
IDENTITY INFORMATION AROUND THE
LGBT. TATE ARGUE COMMUNITY AND
MAKING SURE THAT WE-
UNDERSTAND- WE HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT. WITH THROUGH THE
LENS OF COVERED NINETEEN RIGHT
NOW THE DIFFERENT TYPES OF DATA
SOURCES THAT WE HAVE. AN
UNDERSTANDING HOW WE MIGHT BE
ABLE TO PUT PROVISIONS IN PLACE
THAT WOULD HELP US COLLECT THAT
THAT INFORMATION- UP FOR ONE
EXAMPLE IN CONTACT RAISING- YOU
KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE WRAPPING UP ACROSS THE-
STATE. I EVERY COUNTY. THAT
FIFTY ONE COUNTIES TO AT THIS
POINT I KNOW ARE INTERESTED IN
USING OUR PLATFORM. AND MOVING
FORWARD AND- WE ARE MAKING THAT
PLATFORM AVAILABLE TO THEM AND
THROUGH THE DESIGN AND MODEL OF
OUR CONTACT TRACING- THE
QUESTIONS THAT WE PUT IN THERE
THAT ARE PART OF THE STANDARD
QUESTIONS WILL INCLUDE
QUESTIONS THAT WILL HELP US
UNDERSTAND THIS COMMUNITY
BETTER. AND SO AS WE MOVE
FORWARD THROUGH- COVERED
NINETEEN THIS INFORMATIONAL
BECOME RIGHT MORE READILY
AVAILABLE THAT WILL HELP US
UNDERSTAND- WITH WHAT THE RISKS
ARE OR MAY NOT BE WHERE ARE.
WHERE ARE COMMUNITIES RESILIENT
AND WHERE ARE THEY NOT
RESILIENT WHERE DO WE NEED TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
TO HELP US REALLY- ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES. THAT'S RECORDED
NINETEEN BUT I THINK YOU CAN
IMAGINE THAT ONCE WE PUT IN
PLACE FOR KOBE NINETEEN CONTACT
TRACING- THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN MODEL AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE CAN. CARRY
THAT FORWARD IN OUR WORK EVEN
BEYOND COVERT NINETEEN WERE ALL
COMPETENT AT SOME POINT WE WILL
BE BEYOND COVERED NINETEEN. BUT
WE DON'T WANT TO LOSE THAT MOST
EXCELLENT PRACTICES AND
LEARNING IS THAT WE HAVE FROM
THIS EXPERIENCE AND SO WE WILL
CARRY THAT ORDERED AS WELL. DR
THANK YOU I THINK YOU AT THE
VERY END YOU HIT THE POINT THAT
I WAS GOING TO GO TO NEXT WHICH
IS. IT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL TO.
KIND OF. PUT THAT IN PRACTICE
GOING FORWARD. WITHOUT HAVING
TO DO A. PIECE OF LEGISLATION
OR BUILD MANDATE BUT THAT IS
WHAT EVERY CAN. IS TO DO IN THE-
FIVE NOT JUST IN. BUT EL. AND
WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA IS. YOU
KNOW FRANKLY GIVEN OUR UC
SYSTEM OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
EVERYTHING HERE- PUTS US IN A
POSITION TO BE CUTTING EDGE AND
HELP OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
IN THE WORLD AND SO. I
APPRECIATE YOUR ANSWER ON THAT-
VERY MUCH BECAUSE IT'S SO
MEANINGFUL. TO US SO MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS IN CALIFORNIANS SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. I'M MORE.
LET THE SENATOR BATES HAS ONE
MORE COMMENT OR QUESTION DOCTOR
ANGEL SO LET ME TURN IT OVER TO
HER FOLLOWED BY A DURING THE
QUESTIONING- FROM ALL OF THE
GOOD VICE CHAIR. REGARDING THE
DATA AND I THINK IT'S A REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTION REGARDING
THE DATA THAT'S USED FOR
OPENING UP. A VERY A FIVE
FACILITIES AND NOW I
ENTERTAINMENTS IN CALIFORNIA
THERE WAS A BIG A PROBLEM IN
ORANGE COUNTY WHEN OUR BEACHES
WHERE IT OPENED AND YET LOS
ANGELES COUNTY'S BEACHES WERE.
THEY HAD A HIGHER- DEATH RATE
THEY HAD A HIGHER AYE INFECTION
RATE A HIGHER- HOSPITALIZATION
RATE. SO THE CONSTITUENTS GET
UPSET WHEN THERE IS KIND OF A
COOKIE CUTTER APROACH. TO AND
IF YOU CAN OPEN AND NOT OPEN
AND THE E. R. COMMUNITIES HAVE
NOT ON. THOSE HIGH NUMBERS HAVE
BEEN YOU KNOW VERY DIFFERENT
DISENGAGE AND ARE SUPPORTING.
OUR HEALTH WORKERS SO ARE YOU
IS THE BEACH EGGS HOLD BECAUSE
THERE WAS NO REASON THAT ORANGE
COUNTY'S BEACHES COULDN'T
OPENED AT THE SAME TIME THAT
STILL QUESTIONABLE BY.
COMMUNITY THAT HAD HIGHER RATE
FOR OPENED IN A WE WERE NOT
ALLOWED TO. SO I GET FIFTH
MAYBE NOT A QUESTION CIVIC
DURING BILL BUT. NO REQUIRE
GOING FORWARD. YEAH THERE IS
MORE OF A- INDEPENDENT VIEW OF
THE DAY **** FROM A COULD. SO
THOSE WHO ARE AND I KNOW ACT.
IS DEALING WITH SOME ABOUT
PRESENTLY BECAUSE I'VE READ
MOST OF THOSE REPORTS BUT I
THINK IT'S REAL IMPORTANT FOR
THE COMMUNICATION TO COME OUT
ABOUT YOU WILL BE LOOKING MORE
AT OUT THOSE SPECIFIC. DATA IN
REACHING THOSE DATA POINTS
BEFORE YOU CAN OPEN AND I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO GIVE SOME
CONFIDENCE A TO COMMUNITIES AND
IN PARTICULAR BUSINESSES
BECAUSE BUSINESSES FOLLOWING
THE GUIDANCE OF FAIR THEY
SHOULD NOT IN ANY WAY. BE HELD
BACK NOT NOT TO OPEN JUST
BECAUSE SOME COMMUNITY AROUND
THEM IS NOT OPENING AND I THINK
THAT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN
TERMS OF THE CONFIDENCE LEVEL
GETTING CONSUMERS BACK A TO OUR
BUSINESS SAW MARKETPLACE IN
ENSURING THAT THE BE ALL
COMMUNITIES INDIVIDUAL WHO THE
CONSUMER SPECIFICALLY. ARE
ABIDING BY THE RULES
REGULATIONS THAT THAT
BUSINESSES HAVE TO PUT OUT
BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE A LOT OF
THIS DISENCHANTMENT IS
HAPPENING THAT THERE SEEMS TO
BE A COOKIE CUTTER APPROACH
COMING OUT OF THE STATE AND
THEN EACH. MONEY HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IS EITHER GOING TO
ABIDE BY THOSE STRICTLY BECAUSE
THEY'RE AFRAID OF SOME
LIABILITY WHEN YOU'RE TELLING
US THAT THEY HAVE INDIVIDUAL
FORTY TO MAKE THOSE DECISIONS
SO I THINK THE COMMUNICATION
BEEN POOR AND I'M GOING OUT THE
COMMITTEE I SERVE ON. I WILL BE
BRINGING OUT UP THAT THERE HAS
TO BE SOME STANDARDS IF THE
COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY THEN THEY SHOULD
BE BACKED UP BY A STATE THAT
THEY CAN USE THAT DATA AND NOT-
THAT COMES IN A GUIDANCE AS TO
GENERAL WERE TOO RESTRICTIVE.
IN TERMS OF WHETHER THAT
PARTICULAR AREA OPEN NOT OPEN
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR US FEET
OF. LEGISLATORS AND ANSWER ANY
THE PRESENT SORRY FOR THE TRY
TO EXPLAIN THAT I CAN'T YOU HOW.
MANY CALLS AND HAND THEY CAME
AND THE ANGER WAS THERE IN
ORANGE COUNTY. JUST BECAUSE THE
PICTURE WAS SHOWN REGARDING
WHAT WAS ON THE BEACH AT THAT
TIME I THINK WAS IN APRIL. IN
THE PICTURE WAS TOTALLY
DISTORTED BECAUSE OF THE WAY IT
WAS TAKEN. AND THAT WAS USE
RATHER THAN DATA THAT WAS USED
TO CLOSE THE BEACHES. SO IT'S
JUST A SOMETHING THAT I ANT.
OUR STATE. OF MIND YOU KNOW
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT TO BE
VERY ARE AWARE OF. BECAUSE WE
CAN GET PEOPLE O DO WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO
FOLLOWING THE RULES AND ONE YOU
FOLLOW THE RULES IF THEY FEEL
IT'S DONE FAIRLY. THANK YOU FOR
THAT FEEDBACK. THANK YOU ARE
SENATOR BATES SENATOR MINING
HAS ANOTHER QUESTION OR COMMENT
FOLLOWED BY THE VICE CHAIRMAN
AND THEN I AND THEN WE'LL MOVE
TO PUBLIC COMMENT SENATOR MONEY
THANK YOU MADAM PRO TEM IN.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ANGEL YOU'VE
BEEN GENEROUS WITH THEIR TIME
IN INDULGING OUR QUESTIONS. IN
MAY BE PAYING OFF A LITTLE BIT
OF SENATOR BATES QUESTION ABOUT.
CONSTERNATION CONCERNS BY SOME
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
SOMETIMES VOICE THROUGH THE
MEDIA SOME OF THE COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS HAVE BEEN.
TARGETED VILIFIED I KNOW SOME
OF RECEIVED DEATH THREATS FROM
WHAT CAN YOU DO IN YOUR
CAPACITY TO PROVIDE SUPPORT AND
BACK UP FOR THE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
WHO WERE DOING THEIR BEST TO
MAKE DECISIONS THAT ARE DATA
INFORMED. DRIVEN BY THE DESIRE
TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH IS
YOUR DEPARTMENT ABLE TO PROVIDE
ANY CONCRETE SUPPORT FOR THOSE
WHO ARE BEING TARGETED IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. SO YOU BRING UP A
VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION WHICH
IS REALLY- BEING ABLE TO
SUPPORT THOSE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE ON THE FRONT LINES REALLY-
USING INFORMATION TO HELP GUIDE
BEST DECISIONS AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL THOSE ARE PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS THERE. ARE THERE THERE
EVERY DAY- THERE THERE THERE'S
HOURS ARE AND LISTS AND THEY'RE
AVAILABLE THEY'RE RESPONSIVE
AND SO- WHEN THEY ARE TARGETED
AND IT'S REALLY IT'S A THREAT
NOT ONLY TO THOSE INDIVIDUALS
AND THEIR FAMILIES WHICH IS
INAPPROPRIATE BUT IT'S ALSO A
THREAT TO THE HEALTH OF THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES BECAUSE-
THOSE FOLKS ARE EXPERTS AND-
AND WE WANT THEM. TO BE ABLE TO
BE SUPPORTED AND BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THAT EXPERTISE THE
COMMUNITY THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC
WHICH WILL BE GOING ON FOR
SOMETIME SO WE ARE CONSTANTLY
IN CONVERSATION WITH OUR LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS- WE HAVE
REGULAR MEETINGS WITH THEM
REGULAR PHONE CALLS TO DISCUSS
SPECIFIC ISSUES TO TRY TO
ANSWER WORK THROUGH SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT THEY ARE. DEALING
WITH SO THAT WE CAN AS A STATE.
MOVE FORWARD AND HELP. HELP US
ON THROUGH THE PANDA IN A WAY.
THAT HELPS US GET THERE- NOT
ONLY ON LAW SAFELY BUT ALSO.
NOT MOST SAFELY TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO FOR OUR
ENTIRE SYSTEM WE NEED THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEMS IN BE
INTACT WE GET. THROUGH THIS
BECAUSE THERE WILL BE NO DOUBT
SOME OTHER- EMERGENCY IN THE
FUTURE THIS CALIFORNIA HAS. HAS
AS LONG AND HISTORY OF- NEEDING
TO BE RESPONSIVE WE NEED THOSE
PEOPLE THERE. SO WE ARE
COMMITTED TO CONTINUING TO WORK
DIRECTLY WITH THEM TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR NEEDS AND TO-
DO WHAT WE CAN AT THE STATE
LEVEL TO SUPPORT THEM. WE WORK
THROUGH THEIR- THEIR
ORGANIZATIONS TO THEIR
EXECUTIVE COMMITTEES AS WELL TO
UNDERSTAND NEEDS AND TO BE AS
RESPONSIVE AS WE CAN BE. THANK
YOU FOR THAT THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM AND- JUST A FINAL
COMMENT I THINK. IN YOUR
POSITION PUBLICLY EXPRESSING
THAT SUPPORT AND MAYBE EVEN
CONSIDERING VISITING SOME
COUNTIES- TO ADDRESS COUNTY
BOARDS OF SUPERVISORS OR TO
STAND. BY THE SIDE OF A PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICER WHO'S BEING
ATTACKED WOULD BE. SOMETHING TO
CONSIDER MOVING FORWARD. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR MONNING
SENATOR WILK. THANK YOU MADAM
PROTECTION TO ASK THIS EARLIER
AND I APOLOGIZE FOR SO I WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU FOR ISSUING
GUIDANCE FOR DAY CAMPS I GOT A
VERY RUSTY DISTRICT IN A LOT
URBAN YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN TEAM
BUILDING SKILLS AND ABOUT
NATURE BY BY VISITING MY
DISTRICT AND IN NUMEROUS DAY
CAMPS. I GOT A CALL FROM A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR THIS IS THIS
NOT EVEN IN MY AREA BUT THEY
HAVE A VERY LARGE OVERNIGHT
CAMP IN PLACE A HUNDRED FIFTY
PEOPLE AND THEY WILL WANT TO
LET THEM OPEN BUT THE THEY'VE
BEEN. OPEN AND THERE'S STATE IS
MAY BEAT LATE NOW BASED
CONSIDERING ALREADY THE MIDDLE
IN JUNE BUT YOU DO YOU FOR SEE
WHEN YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
GUIDELINES FOR OVERNIGHT CAMPS.
WE I DON'T HAVE A DATE FOR YOU
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
DOCTOR ANGEL ARE WE ARE GOING
TO GO TO- WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF THE NOMINATION OR THE
CONFIRMATION- AND WE'LL START
WITH- ANYONE IN THIS ROOM FOR
TWO OH THREE. OR TO THE PUBLIC
IN SUPPORT. OKAY AND I'M GONNA
ASSUME SINCE NO ONE IS HERE IF
VISIBLE IN THIS ROOM THAT
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY BUT LET'S JUST GO TO THE
ROOM MAKE SURE WE'RE COVERING
OUR- BASIS AND- ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. SEEING NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WE ARE NOW GONNA-
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. SO I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE A MODERATOR OUT
THERE AND I IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF DOCTOR
ANGEL WILL BEGIN. CERTAINLY
CHAIRPERSON ATKINS. REASON
GERMAN SHOW SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN IS ZERO AT THIS
TIME AN OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE
YOU WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND
FURTHER INSTRUCTIONS. IF YOU
ARE USING A SPEAKER PHONE
PLEASE PICK UP THE HANDSET
BEFORE PRESSING THE NUMBERS. WE
WILL START WITH LINE NUMBER
TWELVE LINE TWELVE YOU'RE OPEN
YOU MAY GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
KELLY BEING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING OVER FIFTY
THOUSAND FOR THIS MEMBERS
SUPPORTING THE APPOINTMENT OF
DR SONI ANGEL AS THE DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND STATE HEALTH
OFFICER THE WORK PERFORMED BY
C. PH TOUCHES OUR LIVES EVERY
DAY IN EVERY COMMUNITY AND THEN
EVERY CORNER OF CALIFORNIA.
DOCTOR ANGEL IT HELPED ENSURE
THAT CIENCE UNDER GROUPS
CALIFORNIA'S COPE WITH NINETEEN
PANDEMIC RESPONSE. TO STAY AT
HOME ORDER DOCTOR ANGEL LISTED
ISSUED ON MARCH NINETEENTH WITH
THE CRITICAL EARLY STEP AND
HELPING CALIFORNIA FOR THE
TRANSMISSION OF THE DISEASE.
UNDER HER LEADERSHIP CD PH IS
PROVIDING CALIFORNIA'S MANY
ECONOMIC SECTORS THE DETAILED
GUIDANCE THEY NEED. TO RESUME
ACTIVITIES IN A MANNER THAT
REDUCES RISK OF EXPOSURE AND
TRANSMISSION. WE RESPECTFULLY
SUPPORT THE CONFIRMATION OF
DOCTOR ANGEL DIRECTOR AND
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THE QUALIFIED POSITION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
NEXT WITNESS WILL COME FROM
LINE NUMBER NINETEEN LINE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM PROTON THE
NUMBERS AND I THINK YOU KNOW
WHAT KEEP YOU PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF TO SKATE ON BACK TO
CONTROL ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE PLEASED
TO SUPPORT DOCTOR USUAL
CONFIRMATION. TO THIS CRITICAL
POSITION. NBC AC HAVE LONG
ENJOYED A STRONG WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WITH THAT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND EFFECTIVE BORN
DETECTION AND- LOCAL MOSQUITO
CONTROL DISTRICT WELL NOT
REGULARLY PRODUCT IN THEIR
CAPACITY AS A PUBLIC HEALTH
DEFENDER. PLEASE YOU CALL AND
PROTECTING PUBLIC IN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES FROM TRAINS THAT
BOTH OF THESE THE- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
COLLABORATIVE WORK WITH DR IN.
DEPARTMENT OF THE INTEGRAL PART
OF THE OVERALL PUBLIC. HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. MR MONTEREY NEXT.
NEXT WITNESS WILL COME FROM
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN LINE
THIRTEEN YOUR OPEN. HI MEDICARE
MEMBERS PARKS DEEPER WITH THE
HEALTH OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THAT
CITY AND COUNTY HEALTH OFFICER.
AND THAT SENATOR MONEY MISSION
ST THANK YOU FOR ASKING THAT
QUESTION IS IF YOU DR EAGLE FOR
YOUR SHOW SUPPORT WE SUPPORT
AND DOCTOR ANGEL SHE'S BEEN
WORKING WITH A COLLABORATIVE
LEECHES THE START OF THE
PANDEMIC MEETING WITH US ON A
VERY FREQUENT BASIS. AND WE
HOPE THAT YOU BE CONFIRMED
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. B<c.cyan> ALIGN</c>
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE TWO FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN BIRTH
MICHELLE GIVEN BUT THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND ALSO
WANTED BECAUSE THE PART OF
DOCTOR ANGEL CONFIRMATION
TODAY- I'D ECHO THAT IT'S NO
SMALL FEAT THE NEW REPUBLIC
STATE PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER IN
P. PEACH DIRECTOR. AT THE
LEADING OUR STATE THAT CAN AND
THEN ALL WHO WOULD REITERATE
THAT IN THE EARLY MONTHS SHE
WAS FILLED WITH RESPONDING TO
WILD FIRES THAT WE HAVE HAD. A
LOT OF ENGAGEMENT WITH DOCTOR
ANGEL OVER THE MONTH THAT SHE'D
BEEN AND THEN IN HER ROLE. WE
APPRECIATE. OR OF LOCAL COLOR
HEALTH. WE APPRECIATE CLAPPER.
AND THE REGULAR MEETINGS AND
CALL THAT WE HAVE HAD. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO. ADDITIONAL GREAT
WORK THAT WE CAN DO TOGETHER
COLLABORATIVELY ADD TO FURTHER
THAT PUBLIC HEALTH. I WE KNOW
THAT LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS ARE VITAL PARTNERS
THE WORK THAT WE DO ALSO
INTERSECT WITH THE WORK AT THE
STATE DOES AND WE HAVE TO WORK
IN COORDINATION IN ORDER TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT. SO WE'RE
PLEASED TO PART AFTER ANGEL
THAT CONFIRMATION TODAY AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE GREAT LOOK
AHEAD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WITNESS WILL BE
LINE TWENTY TWO ZERO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR JEREMY CAME ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES WE REPRESENT ALL
FIFTY EIGHT- FOR THE
SUPERVISORS IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT DOCTOR
ANGEL CONFIRMATION THE DAY SHE
AND HER DEPARTMENT THROUGH THE
ENTIRE SPRING HAVE MADE
THEMSELVES AVAILABLE TO OUR
MEMBERS AND STAFF- ALL HOURS OF
THE DAY EVENING WEEKEND YOUR
NAME THAT WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE COUNTIES- ON BOTH STRATEGY
MOVING FORWARD- SHE'S ALWAYS
BEEN OPEN. TO ANY ANY ANY.
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT SHE
RECOGNIZABLE COUNTIES THAT WE
PLAY- AS WELL AS THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE- AND
FOR THOSE REASONS YOU TRONG
WITH THE BORDER CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND NO REFLECTION OF THE PERSON
WHO JUST SPOKE BUT JUST A
GENERAL REMINDER TO FOLKS TO
SPEAK SLOWLY. AND CLEARLY-
MISTER MODERATOR NEXT WITNESS.
ACCESS WILL BE LINE NUMBER
TWENTY SIX TWO SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THANK YOU THIS IS BARBARA
GLAZER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS. CALIFORNIANS FORTUNATE
TO HAVE DOCTOR ANGEL WHO BRINGS
A HIGHLY ACCOMPLISHED CAREER IN
PUBLIC HEALTH. DOCTOR ANGEL'S
LEADERSHIP AS PART OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO RESPOND TO THE
CODED NINETEEN PANDEMIC AT
STATE COUNTLESS LIVES. INFORMED
PREPARED AND DEDICATED SHE HAS
WORKED TIRELESSLY OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL MONTHS TO PROTECT THE
HEALTH OF ALL CALIFORNIANS WORK
AT SURCHARGE TESTAMENT TO HER
CREDENTIALS AND TEMPERAMENT SHE
TURNED HER TENURE THE
DEPARTMENT HAS PARTNERED WITH
THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY SYSTEM
TO SEARCH THE CAPACITY TO CARE
FOR KOBE NINETEEN PATIENT. AND
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPAND THE
CAPACITY PROTECTING THE GUY
KNEW THE DEPARTMENT HAD THREE
LEASE ON OPEN NINETEEN UNDER
DOCTOR ANGEL LEADERSHIP HAS
BEEN CRITICAL TOP HOSPITALS AND
HEALTH SYSTEMS HAVING THE
LATEST. CUTTING EDGE
INFORMATION TO PROTECT PATIENT
EMPLOYEES STAFF. FURTHER DOCTOR
ANGEL AND HER EXECUTIVE TEAM
HAVE TAKEN A COOPERATIVE
APPROACH WITH STAKEHOLDERS
WITHIN AND SEEKING TO
UNDERSTAND THE EXPERIENCE OF
HEALTHCARE LEADERS IN ORDER TO
INCREASE ACCESS TO CARE AND
PROTECT VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION IS PLEASED TO WORK
WITH DOCTOR ANGEL AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT SHE
BE CONFIRMED AS DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH IN STATE PUBLIC. HEALTH
OFFICE HERE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS
MISTER MOM. OUR NEXT WITNESS
WILL COME FROM A NUMBER TWENTY
SEVEN TWO SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBERS BENJAMIN TRAD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK LOOKING SUPPORT FOR
DOCTOR ANGEL'S APPOINTMENT A
STRICTER OF DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. FORD TO WORKING
WITH DOCTOR ANGEL AND HER TEAM
TO ADDRESS KALRA NINETEEN
DISPARITIES ANY MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
IN PARTICULAR WE HOPE TO SEE
YOU PH TAKES THAT. PAIN YOU
CALIFORNIA REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT WHICH SERVES THE MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF ON A POP FOR
LOW POPULATIONS WE ARE EAGER TO
WORK COLLABORATIVELY TO INSURE
EQUITY HI FOCUS AT THE
DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WITNESS WILL BE
FROM ONE NUMBER TEN LINE TEN
YOUR OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
NATALIE SHARE NUMBERS CLIENTELE
COTTO ON BEHALF OF- TO KOREAN.
STATEMENT WE HAVE TO DISTRICT
HOSPITAL LEADERSHIP FARMWORKERS
AND THIRTY FIVE TO TEN MINUTES
AGO HOSPITAL. FOR A
CONFIRMATION OF DOCTOR ANGEL. A
CHALLENGING DOCTOR ANGEL HAD
FACE SHOWN MOAKLEY QUALIFIED AS
DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE
COULD PROGRAM. CALIFORNIA EVERY
DAY. A DIFFICULT THE LEADERSHIP
PARLIAMENT MEMBER HOSPITALS ARE
CREATED TO EXPAND THE ACCENT
THE TOPIC OF THE BILL ALL
CALIFORNIANS. SPECIALLY LOW
INCOME PATIENTS ACROSS ALL
AREAS OF THE STATE BY IMPROVING
POPULATION HEALTH PATIENT
QUALITY AND REDUCE COSTS. OUR
MEMBERS LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH DOCTOR ANGEL TO ADDRESS
HEALTH CARE NEEDS ALL
CALIFORNIA. AND WE PURPORT HER
CONFIRMATION. ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY SB HEALTH DIRECTOR THAT
CREATION THE INCREASE DIRECTOR
OF THE PUBLIC BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
REPRESENTED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE NUMBER INCREASE AT THAT
POINT THE CONFIRMATION OF
DOCTOR ANGEL. DOCTOR ANGEL
OFFERS ADAPTED DEATH OF
EXPERIENCE AND KNOWLEDGE THAT
QUALIFIED HER SERVICE DIRECTOR
THE MAJOR SHIP IN ADDITIONAL
DURING THE- ACTIVE COMBAT
NINETEEN CONDEMNING HAVE PLAYED
A SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN HELPING
CALIFORNIA FLATTEN THE CURRENT.
CHALLENGES IN YOUR BAKER BERMAN
THAT SHE IS LOCAL QUALIFY THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH WHICH IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR PROGRAM ACTING.
THE CALIFORNIA EVERY DAY.
CREATED PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
FOR THE OVERALL HEALTH AND WELL
BEING OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
TRACKING ADDRESSING. UNDER THE
HELP UNDER THE OFFICE OF HEALTH
EQUITY IN TERMS OF THE COURT TO
THE POINT COMPREHENSIVE HARM
REDUCTION RELATED POLICY. STATE
AND LOCAL LEVEL HAVE A HEART
HEALTH DIRECTOR EVERY COUNTY I
THE STATE THE COLOR TO WORKING
WITH DOCTOR ANGEL TO ADDRESS.
THE HELP THE HELP ALL
CALIFORNIANS. AND WE ACTUALLY
ASK. TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- LET ME ASK WITNESSES A AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SPEAKING
SLOWLY CLEARLY GIVING YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION BUT I'M GOING
TO ASK YOU I WANT TO HEAR YOUR
THOUGHTS ON WHY YOU SUPPORT
DOCTOR ANGEL BUT I THINK MAYBE
YOU COULD BE A LITTLE- A LITTLE
MORE CONCISE- WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER APPOINTMENT AWAITING
AND BUT YOU DO I WANT YOU TO
HAVE YOUR CHANCE TO SAY WHAT
YOU NEED TO SAY BUT I. THINK
WE'RE GETTING A CLEAR PICTURE
OF WHAT PEOPLE SUPPORT DOCTOR
ANGEL SO. MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
SPEAKER PLEASE. NEXT WITNESS SO
COME FROM ONE NUMBER TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
PRICE DOUGHERTY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS. CALIFORNIA
SIDE EVEN IF YOU GALA JUST IN
CALIFORNIA THE MILITARY SURGERY
ASSOCIATION. DOCTOR ANGEL HAS
SHOWN TREMENDOUS FORTITUDE
PERSEVERANCE AND HERCULES
COMMITMENT TO PROTECTING OUR
COLLECTIVE PUBLIC CAL. RESIDENT
COPING NINETEEN PANDEMIC ONE
HEALTH CRISIS PASSAGE AND IT
WILL WE ARE COMPLETELY
CONFIDENT THE DOCTOR ANGEL HER
TEAM AT THE DEPARTMENT WILL
CONTINUE TO OVERSEE AND
REGULATE CALIFORNIA HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES AND COMPASSIONATE.
FIRM BUT FAIR MANNER THESE
REASONSWE STRONGLY URGE THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE TO
CONFIRM DOCTOR IN HIS
APPOINTMENT AS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WITNESSES FROM
ONE NUMBER EIGHT LINE EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM AND MEMBERS
MATTHEW MONSON ON BEHALF OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE I'LL BE
BRIEF WE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
OTHERS OR SPOKEN OVER IN STRONG
SUPPORT. FOR THE CONFIRMATION
OF DOCTOR ANGEL TAKE TIME AS WE
FACE THE CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
I DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE ONE
POINT AS WE HAVE SEEN THE
PANDEMIC EXPOSE AND FURTHER
EXACERBATE INEQUITIES IN
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE WELCOME
DOCTOR ANGEL STRONG PERSPECTIVE
IN HER VISION ON THE NEED TO
ADDRESS HEALTH EQUITY AND
RACIAL JUSTICE IS CRITICAL
PUBLIC HEALTH CHALLENGES AND
THIS COULDN'T BE ENOUGH AT THIS
TIME. WE BELIEVE DAHLE TO ANGEL
AS WELL PLACE TO TACKLE
CHALLENGES HEAD ON AND TO MOVE
CALIFORNIA TOWARDS A BETTER
FUTURE WHAT THE PUBLIC HEALTH
NEEDS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS I MET
AND WE ORIGINAL CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. THANKS WITNESSES
NUMBER SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN IN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SHE GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS IS TONY KANNADA ON BEHALF
OF THE NURSE FAMILY PARTNERSHIP
MATERNAL CHILD HEALTH PROGRAM
THAT IMPROVES PREGNANCY OUT-
IMPROVE MATERNAL AND INFANT
HEALTH AND CHILD WELFARE. AND
INCREASE THE TRAM WITH ECONOMIC
SELF SUFFICIENCY. AT THE
PROGRAM THAT SERVES THOUSANDS
OF CALIFORNIA FAMILIES EACH
YEAR TO THE USE OF SPECIALLY
TRAINED TO PUBLIC HEALTH NURSES
IN TWENTY ONE COUNTIES. AND HE
PROUDLY AND EXCITEDLY SUPPORT
STRUCTURE ANGELA APPOINTMENT.
WE APPRECIATE OUR COMMITMENT TO
PREVENTIVE INTERVENTIONS
IMPLEMENTED UNDER HER
LEADERSHIP AT THE NEW YORK CITY
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH AND MENTAL
HYGIENE AND ANTICIPATE SHE'LL
CONTINUE THAT TRADITION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS WHO ARE AND
ASKING FOR THE CALIFORNIA HAVE
BEEN ON THE FRONT LINES OF
THEIR COMMUNITIES COATED
RESPONSES. MAY HAVE SEEN THE
KIND THAT THEY USUALLY SPEND
WITH THE FAMILY BE REASSIGNED
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. BUT DONT
BUT DOCTOR AND TO THE POINT
WHERE WE LOOK FORWARD TO BEING
A PARTNER WITH HER AND THE
DEPARTMENT TO BALANCE THE NEED
TO PROVIDE ESSENTIAL PREVENTIVE
HEALTH INTERVENTIONS I AND AT
PEACE NURSES FROM TODAY IN%
PROGRAM. RESPONSE OF
INTERVENTION BUT ARE CRITICAL
TO MITIGATING THE EFFECTS OF ON
GOING AND DIVERSE PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISES LIKE HOPE THAT WERE
PROUD TO BE PART OF THIS
PARTNERSHIP THANK YOU. THANK.
YOU SO MUCH NEXT WITNESS. AND
WE HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. THAT'S
LINE TWENTY TWO TWENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
ALEX DAVIS I'M CALLING WITH
LEADING AGE WE REPRESENT OFTEN
YOU'RE LIVING PROVIDERS AND WE
JUST. LIKE TO ECHO. THE
COMMENTS MADE UP FOR ME AND
SUPPORT. OF DOCTOR INITIAL
APPOINTMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND MISTER
MODERATOR I THINK HE SAID WE
HAD ONE MORE ARE WERE CHECK IN
THE LAW AND- WE HAVE NOW
EXHAUSTED THE ENTIRETY OF THE
QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER MODERATOR I'M SURE WE'LL
BE BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A
MOMENT- BUT WE WILL RETURN ON A
TWO FOUR TWO OH THREE AND TAKE
UP ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO ONE HERE ARE COMING
FORWARD IN OPPOSITION FOR.
PURPOSES OF PROCESS WE WILL
CHECK ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SEEING
NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MISTER MODERATOR I AM COMING
BACK TO YOU TO SEE IF WE HAVE
PEOPLE ON THE LINE WHO WISH TO
REGISTER THEIR OPPOSITION TO
THE APPOINTMENT. THOSE ON THE
AUDIO LINES IF YOU WISH TO
VOICE OPPOSITION YOU MAY DO SO
BY PLACING YOURSELF FROM THE
QUEUE BY PRESSING ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
PERSON ACTING SIRS KNOWN
QUEUING UP IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES AT THIS TIME. OKAY
OF. MISTER MODERATOR THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE APRECIATE YOUR
ASSISTANCE I WILL BRING IT BACK
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
SENATOR ROTH HAS MADE A MOTION
OF SUPPORT. SEEING NOTHING
FURTHER MADAM SECRETARY WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BATES.
FIVE EIGHT FIVE MINING. NINE ON
I ROTH FIVE ROTH AYE WILK. WILK
NOT VOTING ATKINS FIVE INSIDE
DOCTOR ANGEL CONGRADULATIONS
FOR ZERO AND WE COMMEND YOU FOR
YOUR WORK YOUR CONFIDENCE AND-
WE SHOULD THE BEST WE NEED YOUR
EXPERTISE FOR SURE RIGHT NOW ON
OUR STATE SO CONGRATULATIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED
IT'S AN HONOR TO BE HERE THANK
YOU WE ARE GOING TO TAKE- MS
RILEY I SEE YOU THEREREADY TO
GO BUT WE ARE GOING TO GIVE ARE
A STERN ARMOR FOR A FIVE MINUTE
BREAK AND WE WILL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU. THANK YOU.
WHAT THE
HELL. ANOTHER ONE THREE ZERO.
MISS SHE DIDN'T EXPECT THEM TO
EVEN HAD A- OKAY COLLEAGUES AND
TO THOSE- WATCHING THE RULES
COMMITTEE. I'M GONNA CALL OUR
MEETING BACK TO ORDER. AND LET
ME YEAH WELCOME AND SAY THANK
YOU IN ADVANCE TO MS JANET
RILEY A MEMBER OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA BOARD
OF REGENTS FOR HER PATIENCE AND
ALLOWING US A SHORT BREAK IN
BETWEEN THE ODD. THE LAST
CONFIRMATION SO WELCOME- MS
RILEY IT LET ME OFFER YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTRODUCE ANYONE
THAT MIGHT BE WITH YOUR THAT
YOU WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE- THE
SUPPORT YOU AND THEN GO AHEAD
TO MAKE ANY OPENING COMMENTS
YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE AND THEN
WE'LL GO RIGHT TO. THE
QUESTIONS FROM THE SENATE ON
THE WORLD WELCOME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME HERE THIS AFTERNOON I
WISH THAT I WERE THERE WITH YOU
IN PERSON BUT- OF COURSE WE
KNOW THAT CIRCUMSTANCES. AND AT
TIMES DO NOT ALLOW THAT TO DAY.
IF I WERE THERE I WOULD HAVE
CERTAINLY HAD WITH ME MY
HUSBAND CLANS. MY TWO DAUGHTERS
JILL AND ANNA AND POSSIBLY A
COUPLE OF MY SIBLINGS TO IT
PHONE LIVE RIGHT THERE IN
SACRAMENTO MY HOMETOWN. WHICH
I'M VERY PROUD OF. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CAN BE PROUD OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. BY
ALL ACCOUNTS IT IS THE GREATEST
PUBLIC UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN THE
WORLD. WHAT BEGAN AS A BOLD
VISION TO PROVIDE UNRIVALED AND
ACCESSIBLE COLLEGE EDUCATION TO
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS HAS
EXCEEDED ALL EXPECTATIONS. IT
HAS BECOME THE ENGINE OF
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND SOCIAL
MOBILITY TO MILLIONS OF
STUDENTS. ARE THE BACKGROUND OR
INCOME OR RACE TO ME THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SIMPLY
IN BODIES THE CALIFORNIA DREAM.
AS A GRADUATE OF UCLA AND A
PROUD GREW AND I HAVE
PERSONALLY EXPERIENCED THE
TRANSFORMATIVE POWER AND YOU
SEE EDUCATION. NEITHER OF MY
PARENTS GRADUATED FROM COLLEGE
BUT IT WAS THEIR HOPE AND IT
WAS THEIR EXPECTATION THAT ALL
SIX OF THEIR CHILDREN WOULD DO
SO. AND WE FULFILLED THAT
EXPECTATION. THREE OF THE SIX
AND ALSO WENT ON TO OBTAIN
MASTER'S DEGREES MINE IS IN
JOURNALISM FROM THE MEDILL
SCHOOL OF JOURNALISM AT
NORTHWESTERN UNIVERSITY. I WANT
EVERY CHILD IN CALIFORNIA TO
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY THAT MY
BROTHERS AND SISTERS AND I HAVE
HAD. TO BE APPOINTED AND TO
SERVE AS A REGENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY IS ONE OF THE
HIGHEST HONORS OF MY LIFE. AND
I AM SO GRATEFUL TO GOVERNOR
NEW SOME FOR GIVING ME THIS
OPPORTUNITY. I PLEDGE TO SERVE
WITH INTEGRITY DISCIPLINE AND
OPEN MINDEDNESS. THREE OF MY
HIGHEST PRIORITIES INCLUDE
CLOSING THE GRADUATION GAP FOR
LOW INCOME STUDENTS ENSURING
THE BASIC NEEDS OF EVERY
STUDENT ON OUR CAMPUS IS MATT.
AN ASSISTING THE MEDICAL CENTER
IS TO MAINTAIN THEIR STATUS
STATUS AS THE BEST IN THE
WORLD. I THANK YOU AGAIN
SENATORS FOR HAVING ME AND I
AND WELCOME I WELCOME YOUR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISS RILEY I'M GOING TO TURN TO
SENATOR ROTH TO START US OFF
THIS AFTERNOON. THANK YOU MAYOR
PRO TEM I ACTUALLY HAVE NO
QUESTIONS- IN A REGION
CONGRATULATIONS SO LOOK FORWARD
TO MOVING YOUR CONFIRMATION AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
SENATOR. THAT WAS HIS WAY OF
PUTTING THE VICE CHAIRMAN ON
NOTICE THAT HE WOULD BE MAKING
A MOTION MISTER VICE CHAIRMAN.
AT. THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM AND
A CONGRATULATIONS ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT SO WHAT I'VE DONE
I'VE GOT A COUPLE QUESTIONS
THAT I'M INTERESTED IN OKAY SO-
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A PROPOSAL
FOR US IN FACT I THINK IT
CLEARED OUT OF A OUR LABOR
COMMITTEE EARLIER TODAY AND
THAT'S EIGHT. EIGHT FIVE JUNE
FIFTEENTH UC REGENTS
UNANIMOUSLY SUPPORTED ENDORSING
A SAY FIVE WHICH WOULD
OBVIOUSLY REPEAL AS YOU KNOW
PROPOSITION TWO THOUSAND AND
TWO OH NINE. YEAH SO WHAT I
WOULD- EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE CHANGE
THE CURRENT ADMISSIONS PROCESS
FOR THE UC'S. WELL FIRST OF ALL
I JUST WANT TO SAY I AM SO
PROUD TO HAVE CAST THAT VOTE.
AND IT WAS A UNANIMOUS VOTE ON
MONDAY BY THE ENTIRE BOARD OF
REGENTS. AND I THINK THAT IT IS
A CRITICAL STEP. IN THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. AND
BEING ABLE TO MAKE GOOD ON ITS
PROMISE TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE ACCESS. EQUITY AND
ACCESSIBILITY IN OUR
UNIVERSITIES. AND OF COURSE
BEING ABLE TO USE RACE IS JUST
ONE OF THE FACTORS THAT WE USE
IN OUR FOURTEEN FACTORS. THAT
WE LOOK AT WHEN WE'RE LOOKING
AT APPLICATIONS AT FOR STUDENTS
TO THE UNIVERSITY. OF
CALIFORNIA BUT I THINK IT DE.
ANTI HANDS AND WILL REALLY US
THROUGH THAT. AND OF AND I'M
UNDER REPRESENTED. AND
ATTENDING THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT A RECORD THE
FIRST YEAR THIS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IF THE- FINAL
QUESTION WITH THE SUSPENSION
THE S. S. A. T. A. C. T.
REQUIREMENTS WHAT IS THE
PROCESS AND TIMELINE FOR
DEVELOPING A NEW TEST TO
DEMONSTRATE STUDENT
PREPAREDNESS FOR YOU SEE. WELL
IT'S ANOTHER BIG VOTE THAT THAT
THAT THE REGION'S TECH IN MAY
TO SUSPEND AND BASICALLY PHASE
OUT STANDARDIZED TEST THE SAT
AND ACT OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS. WE HAD ALREADY MADE THE
STANDARDIZED TESTS OPTIONAL
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC SO WE
<c.blue>XTENDED THAT FOR ANOTHER YEAR</c>
SO TWO YEARS OF TEST OPTIONAL
AND THEN THE NEXT YEAR. TEST
BLIND MEETING WE WILL NOT USE
THE STANDARDIZED TEST AS A
CRITERION FOR ADMISSION BUT WE
MAY USE IT FOR PLACEMENT. IN
CLASSES AND WE ALSO CAN USE IT
FOR SCHOLARSHIP PURPOSE SAYS.
YEAH YOU KNOW FIRST CITY DOES
NOT COME UP WITH ITS OWN TESTS
AND WE HOPE THAT THIS WILL BE A
TEST. BETTER BLACK TO WE- ARE
STILL. I WENT ENTERING INTO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WE
WILL DROP THE STANDARDIZED ALL
TOGETHER. RIGHT THANK YOU FOR
THOSE ANSWERS ARE LOOKING FOR
TO VOTING FOR YOUR CONFIRMATION
AND WHEN. MY GOOD FRIEND MAKES
THAT. THANK YOU ALL MOTION YEAH.
OUR SENATOR BATES. ACTUALLY ON
MY ARM MISTER VICE CHAIR AFTER
MY QUESTIONS SO I HAVE A NINETY
DAY BUT CONGRATULATIONS ALL I
pALWAYS HONESTY CONFIRMATION
NOMINATION BUT ON YOUR
APPOINTMENT TO THIS VERY
IMPORTANT POSITION I WILL NOT
BE VOTING TODAY ON THAT.
ISRAELI SPECIFICALLY I HAVE A
FEW MORE ON THE BASIS THE TED
SHOT ON THE ISSUE AND IN
PARTICULAR HAS A LOT TO DO WITH
THE SAD AND OUTSIDE THE EASY
SAT AND ACT. A NUMBER OF
CONSTITUENTS ESPECIALLY IN
ASIAN AMERICAN ASIAN- ISLANDER
CLUB. CONSTITUENCY ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THAT NACA SO I
NEED TO DO A LITTLE MORE-
TOUCHING ON THAT BEFORE- I
PREPARED TO OUR SUPPORT YOU'RE
A CONFIRMATION BACK
CONGRATULATIONS AND I DO
BELIEVE ON YOUR BACKGROUND YOU
ARE VERY WELL SUITED BOTH
QUALIFICATIONS AND EXPERIENCE
AND A GOOD UCLA BRAYLON.THAT
HELPFUL BOUGHT SO-
CONGRATULATIONS ON THAT THANK
YOU SENATOR. THANK YOU SENATOR
MINING. THANK YOU MAN CHAIR
AND- MADAM REGION I ALSO WANT
TO ADD MY CONGRATULATIONS AND
APPRECIATED THE TIME WE HAD TO
TALK YESTERDAY AND- TO
DETERMINE IF YOU ARE A- UCLA
BROWN AND- I'M A PROUD CAL
BEARS SO WE SHARE A YOU SEEN-
FOUNDATION IN AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. ONE OF THE QUESTIONS I
DID WANT TO FOLLOW UP ON YOUR
OWN ONE OF THE SUBCOMMITTEES
WORKING WITH ME. BERKELEY
NATIONAL LABS AND WE DISCUSSED
SOME AND I JUST WANNA GET
COMING YEAR THOUGHT TO FOR OUR
COMMITTEE. HELLO THE REGION'S
MIGHT. INTERACT WITH THE LAB
AND- DIRECT SOME OF THAT
BRAINPOWER AND RESOURCES TO
RESEARCH SUPPORTING THE PUBLIC
GOOD IN IN HEALTH CARE AND
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT CALIFORNIANS
FACE ANA I AM AWARE THAT
THERE'S BEEN SOME COVERT
NINETEEN RESEARCH GOING ON
THERE BUT ANY OTHER THOUGHTS
YOU HAVE ON HOW THE REGION'S
CAN BEST INTERACT WITH THAT.
RICH STATE NATIONAL RESOURCE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
MINING AND THANK YOU FOR OUR
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY I AM
VERY EXCITED TO SERVE ON THE
NATIONAL LABS COMMITTEE
UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE NOT HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY I TO CANCEL MY
TRIP TO VISIT THE LABS BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC BUT- THEY ARE
OBVIOUSLY VERY IMPORTANT I
RESEARCH LABS FOR THE
UNIVERSITY I BELIEVE THAT MY
ROLE AS A COMMITTEE MEMBER I
WILL BE TO HELP PROVIDE
STRATEGIC DIRECTION AND
OVERSIGHT AND MAKING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE FULL
BOARD AND I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT
IT WILL TAKE RESPONSIBILITY
VERY VERY SCARY AS- I'M ALSO.
INTERESTED IN SOME OF THE
RESEARCH THAT'S HAPPENING AT
ALLOWED IN PARTICULAR AROUND
CLIMATE CHANGE AND ENERGY AND
ABOUT WATER USE BECAUSE THESE
ARE CRITICAL ISSUES- AND NOT
ONLY JUST YOU ARE STATE TO THE
COUNTRY INTO OUR WORLD AND I
KNOW THAT REALLY FANTASTIC WHAT
IS THAT. I AM NOT HAD THE
CHANCE YET TO GO ABOVE BUT I
CAN ASSURE YOU JUST AS I HAVE
VERY BITTER ABOUT AND VISITING
THE IS I WILL DO THE SAME AND
THAT. WITH A LOUD AND I. FOR
DOING THAT AND THAT MAKE WE CAN
HAVE CALM. AFTERWARD ACT COME
SEE WE CAN TALK ABOUT. THREE
ONE I APPRECIATE NOW FORWARD TO
THAT UPPER. AND THEN WE ALSO
DISCUSSED JUST THE CHALLENGE OF.
ALLEN SING FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT SAN THE UNIVERSITIES
BEING. SOME THE CENTERPIECE FOR
THE EXERCISE OF FREE SPEECH BUT
ALSO BY SOME WHO SEEK TO
DISRUPT AND IN SOME CASES
PROVOKE OR COMMIT VIOLENCE HOW
HOW DOES THE UNIVERSITY
MAINTAIN THAT APPROPRIATE
BALANCE OF PROTECTING STUDENTS
STAFF AND FACULTY WHILE ALSO
PROTECTING FREE SPEECH RIGHTS.
WELL CENTER MONEY I ENJOYED
THIS CONVERSATION AND THANK YOU
FOR SHARING WITH ME THAT YOU
EXERCISE YOUR FREEDOM OF SPEECH
AT BERKELEY AND WE THANK YOU
FOR THAT BUT AS I SAID
YESTERDAY I DO BELIEVE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY NOT ONLY HAS THE-
RESPONSIBILITY. TO PROTECT
THEIR FREEDOM OF SPEECH ON OUR
CAMPUSES IT REALLY HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY TO CELEBRATE
THAT FREEDOM OF SPEECH. AND
SOMETIMES THAT'S NOT SO EASY
AND WE'RE SAYING THAT AND WE'VE
INVITED FOLKS ON OUR CAMPUSES
BEFORE AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
DO SO. WHO SPEECH WE MAY NOT
AGREE WITH. AND WHOSE POINT OF
YOU MAY BE VERY DIFFERENT THAN
OUR OWN AND- SPEECH WE MAY
ACTUALLY AB FOR BUT WE MUST
PROTECT THAT FREEDOM OF SPEECH
AS IS GUARANTEED. BY THE FIRST
AMENDMENT NOW OF COURSE WE HAVE
TO ALWAYS BALANCED OUT WITH THE
SAFETY OF OUR STUDENTS. OF OUR
FACULTY ARE WORKERS ON CAMPUS
AND SO THEY WILL HAVE TO THE
GUARD RAIL. WE WILL TO
SOMETIMES RISK. THAT AT TO
CERTAIN. THAT THE CAMPUS AT
CERTAIN TIMES- AND OF COURSE
ANY KIND OF SPEECH THAT INCITES
VIOLENCE AND SHOULD NOT AND
WILL NOT BE PROTECTED- ON THE
CAMPUS SAYS AND I FEEL VERY
VERY STRONGLY ABOUT THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN I'M-
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST IN YOUR
ROLE I THINK HERE WELL EQUIPPED
IN ENTHUSIASTIC- FOR THIS WORK
AND AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME I
LOOK FORWARD TO VOTING FOR YEAR
CONFIRMATION THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. AT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH US SENATOR MINING-
MISERABLY I HAD AN ENJOYABLE
CONVERSATION WITH YOU- AND I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I THINK
IT WAS THIS WEEK BY THE DAYS
HAVE BEEN LONG- BUT I ALSO I
JUST REALLY APPRECIATED YOUR
OPENING COMMENTS IN YOUR
PRIORITIES THAT YOU'RE VERY
CLEAR. ABOUT WHY YOU'RE THERE
WHAT YOUR PRIORITIES ARE AND IN
PARTICULAR I YOU KNOW THE ISSUE
OF FOOD SECURITY A PRIORITY
ISSUE HAVE ARE APPROPRIATE AND
WELL PLACED AS A REGION. YEAH
IN STORE THAT SECURITY IS ON
THAT LIST I REALLY APPRECIATE-
I AM GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC I
THINK I GET EVERYONE'S COMMENTS
SO WITH THAT ARE LET ME DO A
REMINDER WE WILL MOVE TO OUR-
FOLKS ARE HERE IN TED IN TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT BUT I WANT
TO GIVE A REMINDER TO WITNESSES
WHO MAY WANT TO. COMMENT VIA
TELEPHONE AND A REMINDER THAT
OUR PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER WILL AGAIN BE PUT ON THE
SCREEN IT IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
AND THE CODE IS. SEVEN FIVE
ZERO TWO ZERO ONE THREE. AND WE
WILL START WITH WITNESSES IN
ROOM FOUR TWO OH THREE IN
SUPPORT OF MS RILEY'S
CONFIRMATION. OKAY SEEING NONE-
WE WILL GO TO OUR ROOM TWENTY
FORTY JUST TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
NOT MISSING ANYONE IN SUPPORT.
WE ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO
MISTER MODERATOR- VIA
TELECONFERENCE. AND I ASK- THE
MODERATOR TO PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELECONFERENCE. IF YOU WISH TO
TESTIFY VIA PHONE LINES YOU MAY
DO SO BY PUTTING YOURSELF IN
THE QUEUE WITH THE ONE AND THEN
ZERO COMMAND. THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE DO NOT HAVE A
COUPLE OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
QUEUING UP PLEASE ALLOW SIMILAR
TO PROVIDE THEM THEIR LINE
NUMBERS. AND WE'RE GONNA GO TO
LINE NUMBER TWENTY NINE LINE
TWO NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THANK YOU GO AHEAD. YES SENATE
RECKONS ARE YOU RECOGNIZE ME. I
BELIEVE I RECOGNIZE THE VOICE
MISTER SPEAKER AND I'D- CHAIR
OF THE UC BOARD OF REGENTS
MISTER JOHN CARESS GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND THANK YOU
ALL SENATORS- I JUST WANTED TO
CALL AND THEN AT THE RISK OF
HURTING THE- NOMINEES CHANCE OF
CONFIRMATION TO ADD MY VOICE IN
SUPPORT OF- FOR CONFIRMATION
TODAY'S YOU COULD SEE SHE'S
INCREDIBLY- COMMITTED AND
DILIGENT MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
REGENTS AND THERE'S BEEN AN-
INCREDIBLE ASSET NOW I WOULD
HOPE THAT YOU WOULD DAHLE
LASSIE FIT CONFIRMING HER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER. NEXT
WITNESS. WE HAVE ONE MORE IN
THE QUEUE THAT IS LINE NUMBER
SIXTEEN LINE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
PRO TEM AND MEMBERS I'M JIM
HOLLY I. AM THE MANAGER FOR
STATE RELATIONS AT LAWRENCE
BERKELEY NATIONAL LABORATORY.
TOUR IN SUPPORT OF THE
CONFIRMATION OF REGION RILEY.
AS YOU KNOW LAWRENCE BERKELEY
FEDERAL FUNDING EXPERTISE IN
UNIQUE RESEARCH FACILITIES.
STRENGTHENED RESEARCH
OPPORTUNITIES AND CAPABILITIES
FOR ALL CAMPUES IN THE ENTIRE
YOU. FROM AND AS A MEMBER OF
NATIONAL LABORATORIES COMMITTEE
BRIDGET RILEY BRINGS IMPORTANT
COMMITMENT AND APPRECIATION OF
THE LAPS CRITICAL OLD YOU SEE.
DANCING IT'S PUBLIC RESEARCH
THE BENEFIT OF THE STATE AND
NATION AND SHE MENTIONED- QUITE
A WATER- CLEAN ENERGY. ENDING
OUR ENGAGEMENT WITH DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER MODERATOR WILL YOU
SEE IF OTHER PEOPLE HAVE COME
ON TO THE LINE. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO UP AT THIS TIME
YOU MAY DO SO BY PRESSING ONE
AND THEN ZERO. PERSON I CAN
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE GOING UP AT
THIS TIME OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR WILL BE BACK WITH YOU
IN JUST A MOMENT. LET ME NOW
TURN TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION WILL
START IN ROOM FOUR TWO OH
THREE. AND FRANKLY SEEING NO
ONE HERE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
WE WILL AGAIN GO TO TWENTY
FORTY JUST TO CONFIRM. OUR
SEEING NO ONE THERE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION MISTER MODERATOR I'M
COMING BACK TO YOU. TO OPEN THE
LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT MAY WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. MEMBERS ON THE
PHONE LINES IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY
PLACE YOURSELF IN THE QUEUE BY
PRESSING ONE AND THEN ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD. PERSON I
CAN THERE'S NO ONE SHOWING UP
IN OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU MISTER
MODERATOR THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP AND ASSISTANCE TODAY WE
APPRECIATE IT. AND I WILL COME
BACK TO. SENATOR ROTH WHO IS
WAITING TO MAKE A MOTION. THEIR
WEIGHT MOVE THE CONFIRMATION
THANK YOU SO MUCH. SENATOR ROTH
BOB MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BATES.
EIGHT NOT VOTING MORNING NINE
ON AYE ROTH ROTH AYE WILK HI. I
ACTON FIVE HI THAT IS FOR TWO
ZERO CONGRATULATIONS YOU ARE
CONFIRMED AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WILLINGNESS TO SERVE THANK
YEAR IT'S AN HONOR THANK YOU
YOUR OKAY BUT BY. OKAY LET'S
SEE ARE I THINK THAT IS THE
CONCLUSION OF OUR BUSINESS SO
LET ME THANK ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED IN
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU
WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFIED
TODAY SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE. OUR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS AGAIN
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGEST ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT TO US AND WE
WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY
IN THE OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD.
SO THANK YOU AGAIN WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION-
LET ME THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
THEIR PATIENTS COOPERATION WE
HAVE BECOME VERY GOOD AT THIS-
IN A NEW WAY OF DOING AND
CONDUCTING BUSINESS AND I JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK SO
MUCH. TWO MEMBERS OF THE STAFF
WHO HELPED US- DO SUCH A GOOD
JOB AT THIS I WANT TO THANK YOU
AND WITH THAT THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON RULES WHICH IS NOW
ADJOURNED. AND IT WILL TAKE